once again the 9 308th meeting of the
security council's call to order
the provisional agenda for this meeting
is the maintenance of International
Peace and security effective
multilateralism through the defense of
the principles of the charter of the
United Nations
the agenda is adopted
in accordance with rule 37 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
invite the representatives of Australia
Azerbaijan Armenia Bahrain Belarus
the Liberian Republic of Venezuela
Vietnam Egypt India Indonesia the
Islamic Republic of Iran Canada Colombia
Cuba Kuwait or allow people's Democratic
Republic Lebanon Malaysia Morocco Mexico
Nepal Pakistan the Republic of Korea
Singapore the Syrian Republic Sierra
Leone Thailand Turkmenistan turkey
Uruguay Philippines Ethiopia and South
Africa to participate in this meeting it
is so decided
the security Council will now move to
consideration of item two of the agenda
I should like to draw the attention of
the members of Security Council to
document s slash
2023-244 a letter from the permanent
representative of the Russian Federation
to the United Nations uh dating three
April 2023 addressed to the Secretary
General transmitting a concept paper on
the item under consideration I welcome
warmly the Secretary General his
Excellency Mr Antonio Gutierrez
and give him the floor
Mr President allow me to start my
remarks with a few words on Sudan
where the situation continues to worsen
since they started fighting on 15 April
hundreds of people have been killed and
thousands injured
the violence must stop
it risks a catastrophic conflagration
within Sudan that could engulf the All
Region and Beyond
I strongly condemned indiscriminate
bombardment of Civilian areas including
Healthcare facilities
and I call on the parties to stop combat
operations in densely populated areas
and to allow and hinder the humanitarian
Aid operations
civilians must be able to access food
water and other essential supplies and
evacuate from combat zones
I am in constant contact with the
parties to the conflict and I've called
on them to de-escalate tensions and to
return to the negotiating table
we'll continue our efforts with our
partners to secure a permanent halt to
the fighting as soon as possible
working with the military organizations
on the ground we are reconfiguring our
presence in Sudan to enable us to
continue supporting the Sudanese people
let me be clear the United Nations is
not leaving Sudan
our commitment is to the Sudanese people
in support of their wishes for a
peaceful and secure future we stand with
them at this terrible time
I've authorized the temporary location
both inside and outside Sudan of some
United Nations personnel
and of families
I call on all council members to exert
maximum leverage with the parties to end
the violence we start order and return
to the past of the democratic transition
we must all do everything within our
power to pull Sudan back from the edge
of the Abyss
Mr President
thank you for convening the security
Council today around the important issue
of effective multilateralism
multi-level cooperation is the Beating
Heart of the United Nations it's
resonator and guiding vision
the establishment of the United Nations
in 1945 represented Humanity's best
attempts to prevent any repetition of
the orders of two world wars and the
holocausts
over the past 78 years the multilateral
system has held together and delivered
some notable successes
the tools and mechanisms established by
the charter have played their part in
averting a third world war
is making and preventive diplomacy by
the United Nations have helped end
conflicts around the world
United Nations peacekeeping operations
have helped societies move away from
conflict saving
perhaps millions of lives
our discernment and non-proliferation
efforts have helped to confine nuclear
weapons to a handful of states
and the United States Nations was
Central to the decolonization process
and the independence of 80 former
colonies today members of the UN
we have helped to advance economic and
social progress and contributed to
reducing poverty and hunger eradicating
diseases and building recognition
respect for fundamental human rights
the global humanitarian system
coordinated by the United Nations saves
millions of lives each year
and multilateral solutions to Global
problems from the ozone layer to the
radication of polio are tried tested and
proven to work
none of these progress would have been
possible without countries standing
together as a multilateral human family
which makes today's situation all more
dangerous
we Face unprecedented and interlocking
crisis but the multilateral system is
under greater strain than at any time
since the creation of the United Nations
tensions between major powers are at an
historic High
so are the risks of conflict through
misadventure or miscalculation
Russia's invasion of Ukraine in
violation of the United Nations chart at
international law is causing massive
suffering and Devastation to the country
and its people and adding to the global
economic dislocation triggered by the
covid-19 pandemic
elsewhere conflicts grind on from
Myanmar to the Sahel from Somalia to the
Democratic Republic of the Congo and
Beyond
the situation in Sudan now threatens to
be stabilized the entire region
while there are some promising
developments in Yemen and Libya more
than 100 million people have fled their
homes to escape violence conflict and
persecution around the world
effective multilateral responses are
urgently needed to prevent and resolve
conflicts manage economic uncertainty
rescue the sustainable development goals
and address challenges to the global
Norms against the use and possession of
nuclear weapons
we are witnessing a deepening climate
crisis soaring inequalities a rising
threat from terrorism a global pushback
against human rights and gender equality
and the unregulated development of
dangerous Technologies
all these Global challenges can only be
solved through respect to international
law adherence to Global commitments and
the adoption of appropriate Frameworks
of multilateral governance
Mr President excellencies
as difficult as the past year has been I
Martin that member states have made
progress in several crucial areas
abiding treaty on the conservation and
sustainable use of marine biological
diversity was finalized
achieved the Breakthrough in addressing
loss and damage caused by climate change
the general assembly recognized human
right to a clean LCN sustainable
environment
and these developments are important and
their effects could be far-reaching
the Black Sea grain initiative and
memorandum of understanding to
facilitate the export of Russian food
and fertilizers are compelling examples
of the significance of multilateral
cooperation facilitated by the United
Nations
and they clear demonstrate that such
cooperation is essential to create a
greater security and prosperity for all
and I urge their continued
implementation
but you need to do better go further and
work faster
that must start with countries
recommitting to their obligations and
the United Nations Charter putting human
rights and dignity first and
prioritizing the prevention of conflicts
and crises
the principles enshrined the United
Nations chartered and reinforce in the
Declaration on friendly relations and
cooperation among states respect for
sovereignty territory integrity and
political independence of all states
non-interference in the Affairs of other
states the elimination of all forms of
discrimination and the peaceful
settlement of these puts are bulwarks
against uncertainty and fragmentation
they are the foundation of all
International cooperation to end
conflicts save lives protect human
rights and promote social and economic
progress
second age member states to use the full
range of diplomatic tools that U.N
Charter provides for the peaceful
resolution of conflicts and these
include the use of my good offices to
help resolve disputes and secure peace
third effective multilateralism must
include the commitment to tackling new
and emerging challenges and filling gaps
in global governance to achieve the
promise of the charter in the 21st
century
this is the driving force behind my
report on Oklahoma agenda including the
proposed new agenda for peace
the new agenda for peace would offer a
unifying Vision anchored in trust
universality and solidarity
to address all forms and domains of
threats taking a holistic view of the
peace Continuum from prevention
peacemaking and peacekeeping to peace
building and sustainable development
it will underline preventive action as a
priority at all levels
our common agenda envisions
multilateralism that is more inclusive
with space for the contributions of all
countries and communities and more
network with strong links between the
United Nations Family International
financial institutions Regional
organizations trading blocks and others
member states are in the leads on
adapting intergovernmental organs to
meet changing needs a majority now
acknowledge that the security Council
itself would benefit from reforms that
reflect today's geopolitical reality
and this time is true for the Bretton
Woods institutions they do not reflect
also the reality of today's global
economy
the eye level Advisory board on
effective multilateralism that I
appointed last year has identified the
number of transformational shifts with
recipes and security challenges growing
economic inequalities the triple
planetary crisis of climate biodiversity
and pollution and the widening digital
divides
I hope the report will make a
significant contribution to our
Collective reflection in the lead-up to
the summit of the future next year
and by count
on your engagement and support in
preparations for the summit
Mr President excellencies
our institution was created for crisis
throughout its history the United
Nations can overcome seemingly
intractable conflicts and deep divisions
we must find a way forward in that now
as we have done before to stop the slide
towards chaos and conflict
it's time to deepen cooperation to
stress and multilateral institutions to
find common solutions to Common
challenges
members of this Council particularly
those that enjoy the privilege of
serving permanently have a particular
responsibility to make multilateralism
work rather than contribute to its
dismembrane
competition between states is inevitable
but there should not rule out
cooperation where shared interest in the
greater good are at stake
and then competition escalates to
confrontation the multilateral system
founded on the chart at an international
law is the most effective means to
manage disputs peacefully we must
cooperate we must adapt multilateral
institutions and Foster trust where it's
most needed and the urgency of global
challenge is demands bold and Swift
action and I thank you
yeah I think
the Secretary General of the United
Nations for his briefing and I will now
deliver a statement to my capacity uh so
the minister for foreign affairs of the
Russian Federation
Mr Secretary General distinguished
colleagues
it is symbolic that we are holding
today's meeting on the International Day
of multilateralism and diplomacy for
peace which has been enshrined on the
calendar of significant dates of under
General Assembly resolution dating 12
December 2018. in two weeks we will
commemorate the 78th 78th anniversary of
the victory or during the second world
war the defeat of Nazi Germany where my
country with supportive allies made of
this size of contribution
set the foundation for the post-war
International order it's a legal a
foundation became the chart of the
United Nations and our organization the
embodiment of General genuine
multilateralism gained Central
coordinating role in international
politics in 80 years of its existence
the United Nations has delivered on the
key Mission which was entrusted to it by
the founding fathers for several decades
the core Mutual understanding of the
five Mutual of the five permanent
members of the security Council
on the supremacy of the goals and
principles of the charter guaranteed
Global Security and thereby created
conditions for a genuine multilateral
cooperation governed by universally
recognized Norms of international law in
now the United Nations centered system
is enduring a profound crisis the root
cause was the desire of some members of
our organization to replace
international law and the United Nations
Charter with a certain
rules-based order nobody has seen these
rules they were not to the subject of
transparent International negotiations
they are devised crafted and applied
with the goal of countering the natural
process of the establishment of new
independent Development Centers which
are the objective manifestation of
multilateralism their attempts to deter
them with illegitimate unilateral
measures these include barring access to
Modern Technologies and financial
services
they include expulsion from Supply
change confiscation of property
destruction of critical infrastructure
of competitors and manipulation with
universally agreed upon norms and
procedures as a result in global trade
has become fragmented Market mechanisms
have collapsed the World Trade
Organization has become paralyzed and
now clearly and openly the international
monetary fund has morphed into a tool
for the achievement of the goals of the
United States and their allies including
goals of a military nature in a
desperate attempt to assert their
Domination by punishing their
insubordinates the United States has
taken the path of destroying
globalization which for many years they
have taunted they have raised up as the
highest benefit of all of human of
humanity advancing the multilateral
system of global economic system
Washington and it's a western
subordinates
leverage those rules every time they
need to justify illegitimate attempts
against those who base their policies in
line with international law and those
who
abandon the and parochial interests of
the global billion the Western
colleagues have long been found it
inconvenient to reach agreement through
Universal formats such as the United
Nations for ideological Justified policy
to undermine a multilateralism in
abandonment of democracy encountering uh
autocracy Beyond The Summit for
democracy where self-proclaimed has
self-proclaimed a hegemon determines
composition there are other clubs of
Select individuals are adopted the
summit for democracy the alliance for
multilateralism the global partnership
for artificial interact the global
Coalition for freedom of media the Paris
call for trust and Security in
cyberspace all of these and other
exclusive projects have been devised to
undermine
negotiations on relevant themes under
the ages of the United Nations to impose
a non-consensual Concepts and decisions
that are convenient for the west and
these are proposed as a position of the
International Community let's call a
spade a spade nobody allowed the Western
minority to speak on behalf of all of
humankind there's a need to be polite
and to respect all members of the
International Community by imposing the
rules-based order it sponsors arrogantly
a rejected key principle of the chart of
the United Nations namely Sovereign
equality of states the quintessential
nature of the conflicts of superiority
or exceptionism was the lordly statement
of the head of the European Union head
Joseph Burrell stating that Europe is a
Heavenly Garden in the rest of the world
this jungle I would also quote the
jointed Declaration of NATO EU dating 10
January 2023 which states I quote the
United West will leverage all oh
economic Financial political and I would
note this in particular military
instruments at the disposal of NATO and
the use and the EU for the advancement
of the interest of our common billion
that is what the Declaration States the
galactic Blast has arrogantly reshaped
for and tailored processes of
multilateralism at the regional level
for the advancement of their interests
just recently the United States called
for the Monroe Doctrine to be revived
demanding that Latin American countries
limit ties with Russian Federation
People's Republic of China this policy
however came up against the decisive
in a focus of of countries in the region
to strengthen their own multilateral
structures first and foremost the select
and to uphold their legitimate right to
stand as a pillar of the multilateral
world order the Russian Federation fully
supports these Justified
aspirations now there have been
significant forces in the United States
and allies to undermine multilateralism
and is a Pacific region and of this
cooperation around economy and security
has decades for decades been unfolding
around asean this system allowed for
consensual approaches to be established
which were beneficial to the 10 members
or the Dozen members of asean and their
Partners in dialogue including Russia
China the U.S India Japan Australia
public of Korea which provided for
genuine inclusive multilateralism by
advancing the indo-pacific strategy
Washington has embraced the policy of of
destroying this established architecture
and during the last NATO Summit in
Madrid there was an assertion of all
peace lovers and exclusion about the
exclusively peaceful nature of their
military programs announcing Global
responsibility and divisibility of
security in the Euro Atlantic and the
so-called indo-pacific region so now the
policy of NATO as of course a defensive
organization has now moved to Western
shores of the Pacific Ocean the
block-based approaches undermine the
Asia Centric mindsets and they are
manifest in the creation of an of a
military Alliance August which has now
embraced Tokyo civil and a number of
asean countries under the ages of the
U.S mechanisms for intervention in
Maritime security issues have been
established to uphold the unilateral
interests of west of the west of Mr
Burrell who I mentioned promised
yesterday to send EU military for Naval
forces to that region
it is not concealed that the goal of the
indo-pacific strategy is to deter China
and to isolate Russia and this is how
uh Western colleagues view effective
multilateralism in Asia Pacific region
after the collapse of the Warsaw Treaty
Organization and the Soviet Union
departing from this stage a Hope was
fermented for the advancement of the
principles of genuine inclusive
multilateralism in the euro-atlantic
space but instead of tapping into the
potential of the osce on Equitable
Collective bases Western countries not
only preserve NATO but contrary to their
pledges they moved towards arrogantly
absorbing spaces including those
territories where
vital interests of the Russian
Federation existed and will always
continue to exist as was reported by the
then U.S Secretary of State Jim Baker to
President George Bush the Elder the main
threat for NATO is the organization for
security cooperation in Europe and I
would add that presently the United
Nations and what is enshrined in its
Charter also represents a threat to
Washington's Global Ambitions Russia has
painstakingly attempted to reach
mutually beneficial multilateral
agreements with an emphasis on the
principle of indivisibility of security
which was proclaimed and enshrined in
outcome documents of the osc Summits of
both 1999 and 2010 there it states
explicitly categorically black and white
that nobody is to strengthen one's own
security at the expense of the security
of others and no State group of states
or organization
can be vested with the primary
responsibility for the maintenance of
Peace in the osce region or consider any
region of the osce whatsoever as a part
of its sphere of influence NATO trampled
upon these obligations and the
presidents and primaries premieres of
its member states and did the opposite
proclaiming its right to any arbitrary
action an egregious example is the
unlawful bombing of Yugoslavia in 1999
including with depleted uranium being
used which resulted in an uptick in
cancer cases both for Serb citizens and
NATO military personnel Joe Biden wasn't
a senator and he not without Pride he
said before the cameras that he
personally called for the bombing of
Belgrade and the destruction of all
bridges on the Nipper River and now the
U.S ambassador in Belgrade Mr Hill
through media Outlets has called on the
serbs to turn the page and to stop
getting upset about stopping getting
upset the U.S has gained a great deal of
experience Japan has been shamefully
quiet about who bombed Hiroshima and
Nagasaki as we know during these G7
Summit Mr blinken with great pathos
lamented the suffering of victims of the
bombing but he did not
managed to mention the culpability of
the United States these are the rules
and after the second world war these are
criminal Misadventures of Washington
which were set into play these shameful
Invasion by the U.S led Coalition into
Iraq in 20 2003 was an egregious
violation of the United Nations Charter
as was the aggression against Libya in
2011. the result was the destruction of
statehood hundreds of thousands of dead
rampant terrorism
a blatant violation of the U.N Charter
also was a U.S intervention in
post-soviet States Affairs color
revolutions were organized in Georgia
and Kyrgyzstan there was a brutal coup
in Kiev in 2014 and this also includes
attempts to forcibly seize power in
Belarus in 2020 the Anglo-Saxons the
West not only justify or attempt to
justify these criminal Misadventures but
they also taunt their policy of
advancement of democracy and the same
has to do with the rules Kosovo will
recognize independence without the
referendum a Crimea they won't recognize
it despite the fact that there was a
referendum Falklands and melvinas they
will not be touched for there was the
cleverly referendum there this is
laughable in order to abandon double
standards we call for all uh cons to be
adhered to consensual agreements which
were agreed upon through the 1970 U.N
declaration the principles of
international law explicitly proclaims
the need to respect the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of all states who
I quote respect the principle of
equality and self-determination of
peoples and which have governments which
represent all the people residing on
that
territory any
objective Observer can clearly see that
the Nazi key of regime can in no way be
regarded as a representative as
representing the residents of the
territory who refused to accept the
results of the brutal coup in February
2014 and as a result of this uh the
poochists Unleashed war against them
similarly a Christian cannot claim to
represent the interests of cultivar
serves which were promised autonomy by
the European Union just like Berlin and
Paris promised special status for
donbass
the results of these promises are well
known our Secretary General stated this
eloquently during the second Summit for
democracy in 29 March and I quote
democracy emanates from the chart of the
United Nations and his fur its first
words we the peoples reflects the
fundamental source of legitimate power
the consent of the governed the consent
I emphasize this in order to Halt the
war that was Unleashed in the east of
Ukraine a multilateral efforts
undertaken for the advancement of a
peaceful settlement and these were
enshrined as Security Council resolution
which was which which unanimously
approved the Minsk agreements these
Minsk agreements were trampled upon by
Kiev and its Western handlers who
themselves recently cynically and even
with pride recognize that they never
intended to implement this they simply
wanted to gain time time to funnel
weapons into Ukraine against Russia in
this way there was a public proclamation
of a violation of multilateralism a
multilateral obligation of all members
of the United Nations which is enshrined
in the charter and which requires that
all members comply with resolution for
Security Council our subsequent action
to prevent confrontation including
President Putin's proposal dating
December 2021 but for the agreement to
be reached on multilateral Mutual
Security guarantees were high-handed
rejected nobody we were told can prevent
NATO from embracing
Ukraine for all the years after the coup
despite our insistence nobody none of
kiev's handlers brought Prada shenko or
ziliansky or the Ukrainian
upper Vada into their their senses
nobody brought them to their census in
the upper Ukrainian Rada uh through
legislation the Russian language Russian
education Russian media outlets and
Russian culture religious Traditions
were destroyed in a direct violation of
the Ukrainian constitution in the
Universal convention on the rights of
national minorities in parallel the key
of regime through legislation and
day-to-day life introduced Nazi practice
and Theory without any
concealment openly they organize in the
center of Kiev and other cities
exuberant torch bearing marches with SS
division banners upheld the West
remained silent and this was fully in
line with U.S plans to leverage their
open the openly racist regime in the
hope of weakening the Russian Federation
in a strategic focus on eliminating
competitors it is clear to all even
though not everybody talks about this
it's not at all about Ukraine it's about
how international relations will
continue to be shaped through the
establishment of a sound consensus on
the basis of balance of interests or
through aggressive and volatile
advancement of Washington's hegemony we
cannot consider the Ukrainian the
Ukrainian issue separately from the
geopolitical context multilateralism
provides for respect for the United
Nations charting all of its interlinkage
of its principles and this was mentioned
above the Russian Federation has clearly
announced the goals which we're pursuing
through the special military operation
to eradicate the threats to our security
which were created for years by NATO
Representatives directly on our borders
and to protect people who were have been
deprived of the rights proclaimed
through multilateral conventions to
protect them from the public statements
of a key of regime and their actions and
direct threats to destroy and expel them
in territories where their
the predecessor's lift for uh centuries
what were the U.S doing in NATO and NATO
doing in Yugoslavia in Iraq and Libya
were there threats there to their
security their culture their religions
their languages what were the
multilateral Norms that they guided them
in their proclamations of the
independence of Kosovo and the violation
of the principles of the osce through
the destruction of the stable economic
State economically stable states of Iraq
and Libya which collapsed as a result of
their actions and the the there's places
where located thousands of miles from
U.S Shores they're both the multilateral
system was in a blatant attempt of you
as of the US and there's a clear
imbalance in the U.N Secretariat in the
U.N as a whole and this is now seen in
the staff who are now taking liberties
with politically motivated conduct that
is not befitting of international civil
servants we urge the Secretary General
to ensure that all of its of all of his
staff comply with impartiality in line
with article 100 of the UN Charter we
also urge the Secretariat leadership in
drafting documents on the common agenda
which was mentioned here the new agenda
for peace which is mentioned here to be
guided by the need to suggest to member
states ways to find a balance of
interest rather than helping to advance
neoliberal Concepts otherwise instead of
multilateral of a multilateral agenda
there will be a deepening of a division
between these golden billion and the
international majority speaking of
multilaterals and we cannot be limited
to the international context as a whole
just when we talk about the Democracy
the international context cannot be
disregarded double standards need to be
abandoned and multilateralism and
democracy need to be respected within
States and when their relations one
another everybody knows that the West in
imposing their understanding of
democracy on others is not want to see
democratization of international
relations on the basis of respect for
Sovereign equality of states but now
advancing their rules on the
international Arena they're increasingly
asphyxiating multilateralism and
democracy at home
applying increasingly repressive tools
for suppressing any descent as their
criminal key of regime has done with the
support of its teachers the U.S and
allies distinguished colleagues as was
the case in the Cold War we have reached
the dangerous possibly even more
dangerous threshold the situation is
worsened with the loss of trust and
multilateralism when the financial
economic aggression of the West is
destroying the benefits of globalization
when the United States and allies are
banned in diplomacy and depend demanding
clarification of relations on the
battlefield and this is all done in the
halls of the United Nations which was
created to prevent the horrors of war
the voices of wisdom are these are
undermined and this their their calling
for the Revival of culture of dialogue
and they are muzzled by those who have
decided to undermine the core principles
of multilash literal relations we all
need to return to the source respect for
the purposes and principles you on
Charter and all the diversity and
interlinkages genuine multilateralism on
the international
stage at present necessitates adaptation
of the United Nations to reflect the
trends of the establishment of
multilateral architecture of
international relations there's a need
to expedite reform the security Council
to
enhance representation
of Asian African Latin American
countries the current excessive
overwhelming representation of the West
and this body undermines the principle
of multilateralism of it as well as
Initiative for the group of friends and
protection of the U.N Charter was
established we urge all states who
expecting the charter to join this
there's an important need for uh till it
happened the potential of bricks sco
eurasek cisc sto and of course we are in
favor of actively leveraging the
initiative and positions of regional
associations of countries of the global
South an important role in supporting
multilateralism can be played by the
eg20 if Western participants stop
diverting the attention of colleagues
from pressing matters matters on its
agenda in their attempt to conceal their
own culpability for the accumulation of
crises in the global economy our common
obligation is to preserve the United
Nations as they tried and tested Beacon
for multi lateralism and coordination of
international policies and politics the
key to success is concerted efforts
abandonment of claims for any
exceptionalism and I repeat this once
again respect for Sovereign equality of
States this is what we all signed on to
when we ratified the chart of the United
Nations in 2021 President Putin proposed
the establishment of a summit in the
summit to convince for permanent members
of the security Council the leaders of
China and France supported this
initiative However unfortunately this
was not realized this is directly
related to multilateralism not because
the five permanent members have certain
privileges as compared to the others but
specifically due to their particular
responsibility under the charter of the
United Nations for the maintenance of
International Peace and security and
this is specifically what is required
now under the imperatives of the
un-centric system which as a result of
the actions of the West is evaporating
before very eyes concerns about the
situation are increasingly prevalent in
the multilateral initiatives and ideas
of global South countries from the East
and from east Southeast Asia from the
Arab Muslim world as a general and
Africa Latin America we value their
intention to focus on considered efforts
for the maintenance of a balance of
interest on the basis of The Sovereign
equality of states and indivisibility of
security and to conclude I wish to turn
to to all journalists who are now
covering today's meeting your colleagues
from a Russian and media Elvis were not
allowed access here the United States
Mission Embassy in Moscow and mockingly
announced the willingness to issue Visas
so when our plane took off so I request
insist that you compensate for the law
of the loss of the presence of Russian
journalists try to make your
reporting objective so that the
International Community has a genuinely
multilateral objective overview in your
assessments and the facts provided I now
return to my duties as the president of
the security Council and I give the
floor to Mr Khalifa Shaheen almarar
minister of state of the United Arab
Emirates
is Mr
I want to begin by thanking foreign
minister lavrov for presiding over this
meeting I also thank the Secretary
General for his insightful briefing Mr
President or sustained commitment to
effective multilateralism grounded in
international law and the principles of
the U.N Charter is essential to
maintaining International Peace and
security
in turn defending the principles of the
charter is vital to maintaining
effective multilateralism these
principles including respect for the
sovereignty of all Nations the peaceful
resolution of disputes and the
prohibition of the threat or use of
force against the territorial Integrity
or political independence of any state
are fundamental to the ability of the
United Nations to take effective action
in accordance with the charter
this is critical as the world is
experiencing the highest number of armed
conflicts since 1945.
Force displacement is at an all-time
high
we are struggling to keep alive
the 1.5 degree gold
terrorism and extreism extremism
continue to evolve in a way that
International efforts struggle to Halt
to address our common challenges and
threats to resolve our differences
through peaceful means it is imperative
to promote dialogue and cooperation
among nations we must double down on
efforts to peacefully resolve conflicts
and crises from the Sudan to Ukraine the
following three issues are critical for
multilateralism to have a more positive
impact to people's lives first
multilateralism must serve The Wider U.N
membership The Wider Yuan membership is
a reflection of the rights and
aspirations of 8 billion people and
should remain front and center in our
considerations yet we have a
multilateral system and mechanisms often
struggling to act effectively due to
polarization and competing interests
some member states have always had a
disproportionate influence over the
multilateral system including how these
systems were set up and whether or not
they function in the interest of all
it is the same member states that can
prevent or realize the reforms necessary
to make multilateralism more effective
status quo structures will not move us
beyond the status quo
from the security Council to
institutions like the World Bank and the
international monetary fund multilateral
mechanisms must be reformed to improve
their legitimacy and representation
decisions need to be made with
vulnerable countries not only in mind
but at the table
for example the emerging discussions on
reforming International financial
institutions to better deliver for the
global South offer an encouraging path
to promote stability and improve
equality worldwide
second
protecting Global common goods must be
our top priority
facilitating the peaceful settlement of
disputes promoting human security and
devising Collective albeit partial
solutions for the key threats facing
humanity is the best investment we can
make in our people and planets we have
seen constructive initiatives in the
recent past but this type of
forward-looking cooperation should be
the norm rather than the exception
the historic agreement for a new
multilateral treaty on Environmental
Conservation in the high seas and the
Paris agreement
or specific examples of multilateral
achievements that have propelled us
forward
and finally
multilateralism cannot merely be an
intergovernmental process
the perspectives of all stakeholders
including women as well as youth must
also help drive the conversation
during the pandemic public-private
Partnerships in the UAE from Dubai
port's World to the humanitarian City
supported multilateral efforts to ensure
the global distribution of medical
equipment and covid vaccines
as the incoming president of cop 28 we
see the inclusion of all stakeholders
especially from vulnerable countries as
a Cornerstone of success
the input of women youth indigenous
groups science Academia and the private
sector will be channeled across all
outcomes
in conclusion Mr President we stress
that only by working together can we
promote and deliver peace stability and
prosperity for all nations and peoples
it is time to reform our multilateral
system to ensure that we deliver on the
aspirations of everyone around the world
thank you
blue I think his Excellency Mr almarar
for his statement I now give the floor
to his Excellency Mr Armani mango Deputy
foreign minister for Gabon
thank you Mr President
I wish to congratulate Russia on
convening this important debate devoted
to the ways in which we can make
multilateralism more effective I wish to
thank the Secretary General for having
provided such a lucid outline of the
scope of our debate and the key issues
at play our debate is occurring one week
after the publication of the report of
The Advisory board on effective
multilateralism the recommendations
issued by the illustrious panel
appointed by the Secretary General
reinforce our desire to reaffirm the
very foundations of the harmonious
coexistence of the International
Community and we wish to do this to
ensure greater International solidarity
which will serve as the Bedrock of the
security and dignity of current and
future Generations this quest for
international solidarity is the very
reason that for the United Nations
Charter by signing that Charter each
member of the United Nations
organization has chosen to back
indivisible security
exceeding in acceding to the United
Nations each of the nations of the world
has rejected the
the concept of divided Nations hierarchy
of Nations or nations which impose their
agendas on others
uh this is a Crystal Clear Choice in
trending the Preamble of the United
Nations we present ourselves as we the
peoples of the world as Links of the
same chain of humankind it is this
Spirit which must not only remain at the
heart of our collective security system
but it must also serve as the anchor for
our vision of sustainable development
and of shared Prosperity the ideal
approach which will bring humankind
towards its common Destiny is the
multilateral approach multilateralism is
this down inclusive Dynamic of global
governments based on the respect for and
taking account of each nation's
narrative and that is because every
nation matters every people matters and
every life matters are differences in
size stature and appearance are crucial
additional components of our identity
which not only Define us but first and
foremost mean are what justify our place
and ensure our viability within the
concert of Nations our interdependence
and the fact our Destinies are
inextricably linked our facts constantly
brought before our eyes by pandemics
economic turbulence global warming and
many more are primary threats now are
more than ever transnational and
cross-border in nature Mr President to
overcome future challenges are security
architecture must reflect current
realities we must update our
International institutions our mindsets
and our perceptions of lasting peace
shared prosperity and peaceful
coexistence we must reinvent these
solutions to Modern threats namely
climate change and The Chronic
insecurity of fragile States we must
address the crisis of international
solidarity that crisis fuels the
underlying economic humanitarian health
or food crisis there is absolutely no
way that we will be able to address the
challenges of this Century with the
tools of the previous one Mr President
Africa is the second most densely
populated continent on Earth it is
estimated that it will account for at
least a quarter of the global population
by 2050. it occupies almost 70 percent
of these security council's agenda today
however alas it has no permanent seat
on that decision-making body which holds
Africa's Security in its hands let us
cease to make distressing observations
and come now to issuing tangible
proposals one we must reform the
security Council without further Ado to
make it representative of today's
realities and able to effectively
respond to current and future challenges
of course as an African person I hope
that this reform will prioritize the
common African position and the
legitimate demands contained therein
these are reflected in the esselwini
consensus and these decorations it is
patently clear that Africa will not wait
forever for the vicissitudes of the
intergovernmental reform process to pass
in the eyes of our people that process
is simply an interminable distraction
here I would recall the words of his
Excellency Ali and deba present of
the Japanese Republic head of state when
he spoke at the general assembly of the
United Nations in September he hammered
home the fact that Africa will wait no
longer it is time for redress to be
provided guided for this unacceptable
Injustice which works to Africa's
detriment detriment we will at every
turn submit to Africa's critical mass
the ways in which we intend to act on
this issue two we must redefine our
rules and our mechanisms so that we can
adequately adequately address the
constantly changing security and
terrorism Landscapes as regards rules we
must guarantee inclusivity and
solidarity and Vanquish once and for all
the policy of double standards and
two-track solidarity we must also
decisively tackle the root causes of
conflict and crisis three we must build
a new social Covenant a new Global
compact between Generations between
Governors and the government governed
and one which links action at a global
and Regional level we must give
particular emphasis to the status of
young people and women in this new
social Covenant for the future Bridges
must replace walls everywhere education
must Vanquish the straight jacket of
ignorance and intolerance
multilateralism was must Prevail over
unilateral postures dialogue must
Prevail over antagonism it is a pipe
dream to think that humankind will
survive in bubbles of security and
prosperity surrounded by an ocean of
insecurity and poverty if we were to
labor under that misapprehension the
inevitable alternative to peace and
prosperity for all would be Collective
Decline and the Jeopardy of all of our
Lives we must as a matter of priority
create a shield of actions and
initiatives so that we can
across the world Vanquish the predatory
pillaging of resources and all attacks
against dignity this will ensure that
all peoples of the world will enjoy
security prosperity and greater Freedom
Mr President I wish to underscore the
need to cast aside any desire to defy or
stray from multilateralism several
monologues do not make a dialogue
equally a myriad of bilateral relations
will never produce the effect or far
less have the virtues of multilateral
cooperation multibilateralism leads to
fragmentation it divides the world into
blocks in contrast the vocation of
multilateralism is to build unity and
bridges between we the peoples of the
world we owe responses to current and
future Generations which are
commensurate with their legitimate
aspirations to live in security peace
and in greater dignity these responses
are within our grasp these responses
cannot wait and must wait no longer
thank you
look at the view
thank his Excellency Mr Mongol for his
statement and I'll give the floor to his
Excellency Mr Thomas
Deputy Minister for foreign affairs and
Regional integration of Ghana
thank you Mr President
your Excellency
Mr Suraj
let me Begin by congratulating you and
the delegation of Russia for your
presidency of the security Council for
the month of April
we also welcome the participation in
this meeting of the Secretary General
his Excellency Antonio Gutierrez and
thank him for his insightful remarks
as I make this remarks let me also
indicate that we associate ourselves
with the statement that will be
delivered later by the representative of
the Republic of Azerbaijan
on behalf of the non-allian movement
the multilateral system
that was fashioned out of the ashes of
the second world war has no doubt being
the Cornerstone with some exceptions for
related peace security and Development
Across the world
adherence to the principles in the
United Nations Charter including the
Sovereign equality of states
and the prohibition of the use of force
has been an underpinning pillar for the
global stability
this information migration crisis
food and energy insecurity
the world has never faced
a more profound crisis since the world
war or cold war
structural impairment including the
limitating impact of the V2 system and
the security Council
The Chronic lack of financing for
development a rising geopolitical
competition and a decline in
international cooperation have helped
our effort to renew Global institutions
and deepen multilateralism
in the face of an easy weakness to
reject
or undermine share normative values and
principle for collaboration and
Collective action will raise relapsing
into a new heavy end
state of nature it is not too late to
seek a way out
of the increasingly
confrontational qualities Zero Sum games
and egoistic
chaotic and brutish tendencies
of recent years
it is in the interest of the states
whether small Almighty the safe guide a
multilateral system since the agreed
International rules institutions allow
all vices to be heard and the ability to
influence the international order and
less costly a more sustainable way
Ghana therefore welcomed the focus of
today's debate which provide us with an
opportunity to deliberate on ways that
we can defend the U.N Charter and
promote it always an effective
multilateral system
Mr President
in considering how we can enhance and
effectively rule-based multilateral
system through the defense of the U.N
Charter Ghana will share five main
points
first while it is important to reaffirm
our respective commitment to the purpose
and principles of the U.N Charter it is
equally pertinent that we embark on
practical steps to enhance our
responsiveness to the demand of the U.N
of the charter in this regard we Act
the characterization of the enhance
inclusive MRT stakeholder approach that
enable all actors to adhere to the norms
and values in the charter
this in our view
should be divided politicization as well
as any form of selectivity in
application
we cannot over emphasize the importance
for member states to embrace a principal
approach
and a pain by a common understanding and
good faith interpretation
and the application of the provisions of
the charter
we must also prioritize the will of the
people of the world if we are to achieve
a smooth transition to a fair and
Equitable Global World Order
the cynicism which some countries
display this play in the 15th principle
or Banning them to their will may bring
short-term Tendencies advantages
history shows
those gains are
ephemeral
secondly
a credit recognition of the realities of
our time to spare us all from breeds
deliberate diplomatic actions to build
Mutual trust consistent with a
diplomatic conventions
as my compatriot Kofi Annan once said
our futures our prosperity and security
are wrap up together more than ever
before no country no matter how wealthy
or powerful can any longer stand on its
own
this reality should lead us to build
Bridges not burn them and lay solid
foundations for dialogue and consensus
including using dialogue to objectively
discuss the Strategic intentions of
countries this remain critical for
avoiding misjudgment and healthy
competition especially among majority of
major military powers
within this context it is also important
that we address the structural
impairment in the multilateral system
through a faithful and genuine effort in
the
ongoing reform initiative in the U.S
System including the revitalization of
the general assembly and the reform of
the security Council
as an African member State we have
stated our position and justify our
argument
those who support a strengthening
bilateral system has a responsibility to
reciprocrypt and work constructively and
urgently in good faith to address
with us the historical Injustice than
the African continent which is also one
of the weaknesses a multilateral
structure
thirdly
the multilateral system should be table
charged through an effective
implementation of our objects with
regional Arrangements that share similar
objectives we must therefore enhance
implementation of chapter 8
of the U.N Charter especially around
Regional prevention the United Nations
has its strength but when it is unable
to act the strength of regional actors
must be embraced for instance we cannot
attempt a legitimate resolution of the
crisis of Tourism on the African
continent without a collaboration of
institution of the African Union and the
regional economic communities such as
ecowas as well as the Accra initiatives
in the sahil it is also only fair that
when such Regional bodies stand up and
offer to act the abedding should be
shared with the principal body that owns
that primary Duty
fourthly prevailing Global challenges
are so interconnected and
multi-dimensional that we need to
enhance collaboration and Joint
consultation among different
institutions and drive coherence to
avoid negative and adverse consequences
from global politics this requires We
Believe enhancement of consultation with
institutions and processes outside the
U.N system such as British wood
institutions but also as appropriate
with relevant Civil Society
organizations and responsible private
sector actors to adequately address
pressing needs of the peoples of the
world especially those of the developing
world
this is important because when there are
Global crisis such as the prevailing
financial and food crisis
we should know that further down the
road there will be greater manifestation
of socio-political instability
diminished capacity for conflict
management and federal conflicts
lastly Mr President we believe that the
secretary General's reports on our
common agenda including the new agenda
for peace provide us with a
forward-looking vision for reinvigorated
inclusive and effective multilateralism
to tackle contemporary Global challenges
the initiative and laid the grounds for
Effective multilateralism if they
prioritize
investment in intervention aim at
addressing existing and emerging risks
including those associated with nuclear
weapons and the disproportionate threats
to the countries in the global South
furthermore enhancing the
convenient power of the U.N
in tackling the multifaceted crisis
including climate threats gender
inequality in all it forms and involving
women and youth in peace processes are
all German to strengthen their
responsiveness of the mortuary lateral
system
in conclusion Mr President Ghana
believes that the tools available in the
U.N Charter remain indispensable in
addressing existing and emerging
challenges of our time what is required
is to strategically harness and
effectively deploy these tools
including chapter 6 of the peaceful
settlement of disputes
ultimately the demonstration of stronger
political will by all member States
including this council is essential if
we are to make meaningful progress in
the defense of the U.N Charter I thank
you
all right
Excellency Mr mumba
I now give the floor to the
representative of Switzerland
thank you Mr President I wish to thank
the Secretary General Antonio Gutierrez
for his statement I wish first and
foremost to convey our concerns in the
light of the violence which is currently
raging in Sudan which has unacceptably
been affecting the civilian population
Switzerland joins the call of the
Secretary General
the adoption of the charter of the
United Nations on 26 June 1945
signified a fundamental Paradigm Shift
War once a legitimate means of a foreign
policy was now prohibited
territorial expansion by force
previously the privilege of the great
military Powers was outlawed
the prohibition of the use of force
coupled with the obligation to resolve
conflicts peacefully was revolutionary
these principles placed countries of all
sizes and of all powers on an equal
legal footing or almost the Privileges
of the great Powers were intensely
debated already in San Francisco and
finally accepted on condition of a clear
promise
greater responsibility for the permanent
members of the security Council for the
maintenance of International Peace and
security
as member states we have all subscribed
to the principles and values enshrined
in the charter and we reaffirmed this
commitment in an excellent Declaration
on this occasion of the United Nations
75th Anniversary yet the charters being
violated on a massive scale
State sovereignty territorial integrity
and the prohibition of the use of force
continue to be flouted and this has been
the case for more than a year by the
military aggression of a permanent
member of the security Council against
its neighbor the most effective way to
safeguard multilateralism and the
Integrity of the United Nations Charters
therefore to respect it Switzerland
emphatically
condemns the military aggression against
Ukraine and we reiterate our firm call
on the Russian Federation to without
delay withdraw all its troops from the
entire territory of Ukraine
this open debate it's presented as an
opportunity for the security Council to
demonstrate its commitment to the
Charter and to discuss the strengthening
of multilateralism this is a duty that
we have not just today but a duty which
we shoulder each time we call for the
protection of civilians every time we
condemn violations of international law
and every time we urge the parties to
conflict to silence their weapons and to
return to the negotiating table this is
a duty we have under the Geneva
conventions a success of multilateralism
because the Geneva conventions are among
the few International treaties that have
been universally ratified as the con the
conventions commemorate the as we
commemorate the 75th anniversary of the
conventions next year it is incumbent
upon states to take concrete steps to
strengthen respect for international
humanitarian law this is a duty in times
of Peace as well as in times of War to
respect human rights that serve to
protect human dignity the 75th
anniversary of the universal Declaration
of Human Rights this year will it be an
opportunity to reaffirm its universality
Switzerland firmly believes that
effective multilateralism Remains the
only way to achieve the vision of a
peaceful and just world a world where
the rule of law prevails and not the law
of the strongest a world where human
dignity is always always respected a
world in which finally the entire
population benefits from both social and
economic progress
we are convinced of this because respect
for the charter remains existential for
a small or medium-sized State like ours
as well as for most member states of the
United Nations regardless of whether
this world is unipolar bipolar or
multipolar we're also convinced of this
because the charter and multilateralism
have enabled Humanity to make remarkable
progress such as avoiding to this day a
nuclear confrontation
decolonizing many regions of the world
reducing poverty improving access to
health and education systems making
economic progress and even walking on
the moon and creating artificial
intelligence
we have managed in this form to
negotiate the sustainable development
goals and agenda 2030 which if we
finally Implement them in full can save
this planet and create more equality for
both our children and Grand our
grandchildren it is clear that the
effectiveness of the charter hinges on
the willingness of states to implement
it and this will is too often lacking we
are living in a world of myriad crises
the United Nations estimates that one in
every four young people is affected by
violence around conflict whether she is
a girl under the airstrikes and bartol
in cartoon Bahamut or sagang sexually
abused in Porto Prince of Goma or
deprived of Education in Kandahar the
principles of the charter are not a menu
from which to pick and choose we call
for unconditional respect for
international law by All actors under
all circumstances and we call for the
courage to finally and meaningfully
initiate reforms of the multilateral
system including the security Council
this is necessary to restore confidence
and Trust in and within that system with
our common agenda and a new agenda for
peace we have a unique opportunity but
also an urgent need we must change the
course of history quickly with
leadership political will and Trust we
can achieve this history will judge
whether we have lived up to the Charter
One can deny facts one can leverage
cynical rhetoric one can spread
misinformation but one cannot deceive
the memory of History it will be there
for judgment and the Human family cannot
heal until Justice is delivered for
victims until trust is restored this is
the very first recommendation of the
high level advisory boards report on
effective multilateralism rebuilding
trust through inclusion and
accountability
this trust requires that we listen to
one another let us initiate a dialogue
about what unites us a constructive
dialogue rather than discussions about
the number of centers in this world a
dialogue that reminds us of the
universal principles to which we have
committed ourselves there is no
alternative to effective multilateralism
Universal inclusive multilateralism
based on international law thank you
I thank the representative of
Switzerland and I now give the floor to
the representative of Brazil
thank you Mr President
I think the Russian for organizing this
debate
and I thank Secretary General for his
intervention
Mr President
in this challenging times we should
reinforce our commitment to the
principles of the U.N Charter to
international law and to multilateralism
as members of the security Council we
have a particular responsibility in
preserving the principles and values
based on which the multilateral system
has been collectedly built over the
eight over nearly eight decades
the conflict in Ukraine has added
enormous stress to the multilateral
system
which was already subjects to new
challenges and growing descent
the failure of this Council to
effectively deal with yet another War
falls short of members estate's
expectations on its primary
responsibility for maintaining
International Peace and security and
eventually ends up eroding its
credibility
the International Community
has already proven
to be able to adapt and evolve in
several areas except in peace and
security
for example back in 2008 after the
global financial crisis a group of
countries decided to establish the G20
which proved to be a valuable framework
for addressing New Economic and
financial challenges
besides its deficiencies
such as a limited representation of
African countries it has since come to
be one of the most representative bodies
in the International Community
the Brazilian position on the calcium
reform is known to all
we believe that its current composition
which reflects the balance of power in
1945 is not compatible with the current
geopolitical realities
the African continent and our region
Latin America and the Caribbean
are not represented in the category of
permanent members
these results in the increasing lack of
legitimacy of this body to take
decisions on the peace and security
agenda and under its course the sense of
frustration which the shortcomings of
the U.N system as a whole
Mr President
this is not however the only cause of
the situation in which we find ourselves
in addition to a structural flaws of
this Council we cannot help but notice a
lesser disposition to engage in dialogue
and diplomacy in contradiction with the
spirit of the San Francisco Conference
since the beginning of our current
mandate as an elected member of the
council there have been many occasions
when the demand for sanctions has been
the knee-jerk reaction to crisis
situations
in most cases these initiatives
were preceded by unilateral coercive
measures illegal and an international
law and ineffective
in our discussions
do consideration is rarely given to the
spin-off effects on third countries
especially those which already face
strong economic social and institutional
challenges and their most vulnerable
populations
Brazil rejects the pursuit of a
geminists old or new
in line with Article 2 part 4 of the
charter we come down
the threat or use of the threat or use
of force as means of resolving disputes
as we have seen in the case of Ukraine
we also condemn more subtle attempts to
impose the view of the few on the many
on the basis of concepts of dubious
multilateral standing
we refute word conceptions based on
simplistic divisions that fail to
reflect the complexity of reality an
approach that does not benefit the vast
majority of memory States and only
serves social division among nations
we defend in fact a return to the
principles on which this organization
base its very existence enshrined in the
U.N Charter
with increased emphasis on Peaceful
means to end conflicts
as a founding member of this
organization we have never and will
never condone violations of memory
States territorial integrity
we should not give we should not give up
on diplomacy and should rather seek
Solutions collectively to address the
challenges of our times
diplomacy and peace are the means and
the purpose of the security Council
we must not shy away from this
responsibility
Mr President
the world is going through a moment of
international order redesign
in our review we are heading to some
sort of multipolar order that should be
welcomed and nurtured since it will
benefit the whole of the International
Community
we are aware of the many shortcomings of
the UN system but we continue to trust
the centrality of the United Nations and
its role in preserving peace and
fighting solutions to Common challenges
Brazil believes in the strength of the
multilateral approach on issues such as
climate emergency and on development
needs respecting the diversity of points
of view and National positions
it is essential however that we engage
in an Earnest debate about the need for
a renewed multilateralism in particular
in the field of peace and security
setting aside practices that view only
deepen divisions instead of contributing
to a more peaceful word and I thank you
I thank the representative of Brazil and
I give the photographers additive of
Mozambique
Mr President
Mozambique wishes to reiterate
our hearty congratulations to Russia's
Assumption of the presidency or the
security Council
we are delighted to see you
presiding over this session
we only welcome
the initiative but the Russian
Federation
of convening this open debate
under the theme
we express our gratitude
to the Secretary General of the United
Nations
for his important briefing
Mr President
it is universally recognized
that the creation of the United Nations
represented a new departure
in the human attitude towards Mutual
cooperation
for peace and security
the charter
signed on 26 June 1945
in the aftermath of the bloody and the
tragic Second World War
clearly
Affirmed
the importance
of multi-lateralism
it proclaimed
unambiguously
in the treaty
the will and determination
of we the peoples of the United Nations
furthermore
in laying out
the purpose of the organization
the last the chapter listed for
but the last one some them all
and those friends
as follows and I quote
to be a center for harmonizing the
actions of Nations
in the attainment
of these
common goals
this was in our view
the birth of a new multilateralism
that guides the modern day interaction
between states and Nations
and it is our conviction
that the overriding purpose of these
multilateral lists
is to fulfill the purposes of the United
Nations
Chief among them
the maintenance of International Peace
and security
this resembles very much
what someone someday said
War appears to be as old as mankind
but peace is a modern invention
as a matter of fact
it also resonates with Article 2
paragraph 4 of our chapter
this is
a new approach to war in its nature
innovation of the charter that we
accepted to abide by
it is our understanding
that within this provision of the
charter
the founding mission of the United
Nations
was to provide all its member states
with a solid ground of equal security
our organization who does become
a forum where we could work together
to resolve disputes peacefully and to
prevent the outbreak of Another World
War
in some
the charter proclaimed the overriding
importance of collective security
in this context
equal and indivisible security of states
is at the core of collective security
that the charter consecrated in its
letter and the spirit
the collective security means that the
security of one is the security of all
and the security in our globalized world
is also a global concept
our Global Goods that cannot be divided
or fragmented
this is why in our view
article 51 of the charter
on individual or Collective self-defense
comes as an exception
and a reminder that all states
deserve to live in peace and security
in this connection
it is our view that the relations among
nations
should be based on the respect for the
principle of equal rights and
self-determination of people's
as the most representative
intergovernmental organization
and the atmos expression of
multilateralism
the United Nations
is the main Forum to address
multifaceted and complex Global
challenges through Collective action
so any profound divisions among member
states
can only undermine these important
endeavor
which the founders of the United Nations
undertook two advanced in 1945
in this regards
multilateralism
differently and opposed from
unilateralists implies adherence to
Common principles and objectives
founded on respect for a system of
shared norms and values and guided by
the principles of consultation
inclusion and solidarity among the
Nations
the president
the current Global Security challenges
such as the interstate Wars
Interstate conflicts terrorists
transnational organized crime
proliferation of weapons
limited peacekeeping capacity and
financing
divided in competing collective security
systems
nuclear disarmament among others need a
concerted approach
with a reinforced role of
multilateralism
division is in our approach to
Collective Security architecture
and mistras can only undermine dialogue
the hamper
our efforts for peaceful settlement of
disputes and conflicts
they further weakened the collective
resolve of our Universal organization to
effectively perform its objectives
as Mozambique has stated in this chamber
time and again
peace is a global good
its preservation requires our concerted
efforts
with the Positive cooperation of States
we can find concerted and harmonized
ways to address most of the current and
pressing conflicts around the world
including in Africa Middle East Asia the
Korean peninsula
and even in Europe or Beyond
let us not forget
the tragedies of the two World Wars
that claimed the lives of more than 9
million people in the first and more
than 60 million people in the second
we see no reason whatsoever that this
should be repeated
but all that we evoked above
also Bears testimony to the fact
that the United Nations especially the
security Council
must be reformed
in order to be more inclusive
effective
just fair and Democratic
only in that manner can we collectively
address the current
geopolitical and security challenges
facing the humankind
more importantly
it is a simple corollary of the
fundamental principle of sovereign
equality of states
that the charter so clearly expound this
we value democracy at National level
it must also be valid
at the international level
therefore Mozambique writerates its call
on the need for a security Council
reform
which should take into account
the African common position
based on the zuluin consensus and the
search declaration
in addition
this Council has to improve
its working methods
it must enhance its capacity to deliver
in the interest of all humankind
this means adopting actions that can
bring positive change and promote peace
and security around the world
in conclusion Mr President we wish to
write rate
that in order for multilateral to
prosper and be more effective the United
Nations and the entire membership must
abide by and uphold their principles and
purpose of the United Nations Charter at
all times
multilateralism
must be
reinvigorated
in the interest of the entire humankind
in order to address today's Global
challenges
multilateralism is at the core of our
Charters calling I thank you Mr
President
all right thank the representative of
Mozambique can I give the floor to the
representative of the United States
let me uh start by thanking Secretary
General Gutierrez for uh your remarks
and to thank you and the entire un
system for all of your efforts to
promote peace and security and to
support the UN Charter
and thank you colleagues for coming
together to talk about how we can defend
the U.N Charter and make multilateralism
more effective
this is a serious topic
even if it was convened by a council
member whose actions demonstrate a
blatant disregard for the U.N Charter
at the United Nations if you ask a
difficult policy question
you get 193 different answers
that makes our work challenging but it
also
it is also right because after all that
is what the U.N is all about
member states can work through
disagreements find common ground and see
where we can make progress together
and there are some things we're not met
to disagree about
there are some values and principles
that are so fundamental so critical to
our purpose that signing on to them is
the price of admission to the U.N
these are the values laid out in the
United Nations Charter
a charter we have all sworn to uphold
and to protect
and it is quite clear what those values
are
this little blue book is written in
plain language and it spells out our
purposes and principles in its very
first chapter and I want to read it to
you
article 1.
the purposes of the United Nations are
to maintain International Peace and
security
to develop friendly relations among
nations based on respect for the
principle of equal rights and
self-determination of peoples
to achieve International cooperation in
solving International problems
and promoting and encouraging respect
for human rights and for fundamental
freedoms
and here in Article 2 it states clearly
all members shall refrain in their
international relations from the threat
or use of force against the territorial
Integrity or political independence of
us of any state
territorial integrity
respect for human rights
International cooperation
these are our values
these are the shared
stated principles we all agreed to
uphold all of us
and it's our belief in them that binds
us together
those principles have been the basis for
the un's greatest triumphs over the past
eight decades
despite the international systems
imperfections our shared principles have
helped us curtail nuclear proliferation
prevent Mass atrocities and forged peace
through negotiation and mediation
they have undergirded an international
order that has helped us provide
humanitarian Aid to those in desperate
need to lift over a billion people out
of poverty and to prevent Another World
War
and right now
as much as ever the world needs an
effective U.N an effective
multilateralism
challenges like the climate crisis the
global food security crisis and the
covid-19 pandemic are exactly the kinds
of borderless challenges we need for un
to tackle and yet right when the world
needed the U.N most we were plunged into
a crisis of confidence
our hypocritical convener today
Russia invaded its neighbor Ukraine and
struck at the heart of the U.N Charter
and all the values we hold dear
this illegal unprovoked and unnecessary
War runs directly counter to our most
shared principles
that a war of aggression and territorial
Quest is never ever acceptable and as we
sit here that aggression continues as we
sit here Russian forces continue to kill
and injure civilians as we sit here
Russian forces are destroying Ukraine's
critical infrastructure
as we sit here we brace ourselves for
the next bucha the next Marriott the
next her son
the next War crime the next
unconscionable atrocity
141 U.N member states have made it
abundantly clear
Russia's full-scale invasion was not
about self-defense
Russia simply wants to redraw
International borders by force in
violation of this very U.N Charter and
that goes against everything this
institution stands for
this is not just concern Ukraine or
Europe it concerns all of us because
today it's Ukraine
but tomorrow it could be another country
another small nation that is invaded by
its larger neighbor and what would we
want this Council
to do in response
sit on our hands
no
it is the very reason the U.N Charter
was written in the first place and
unfortunately Russia has shown us
consistently over the past 14 months
that this invasion is not an isolated
incident
in the past 14 months Russia has
weaponized Global Food Supplies and
obstructed the Black Sea grain
initiatives from achieving its full
potential
Russia has breached its obligations
under the new start treaty and issued
dangerous and provocative nuclear
threats
Russia has violated Universal human
rights and fundamental freedoms both
outside and inside its own borders
it has violated international law
that includes the wrongful Detention of
American citizens
Paul Whalen Trevor Reed Brittany Greiner
and now Evan gershkovich
Trevor and Brittany are now thankfully
home safe and sound
but Russia has imprisoned Paul Whalen
and now detaining Evan gershkovich to
use as political bargaining trip chips
human Pawns
Paul was simply in the wrong place at
the wrong time
Evan is a journalist he was just doing
his job
using people as pawns is a strategy of
weakness
these are not the actions of a
responsible country
and while Russia plays political game
games real people suffer
and I want to direct your attention to
the gallery
where today we're joined by Paul's
sister Elizabeth
and I want minister lavrov
to look into her eyes and see her
suffering
I want you to see what it's like to miss
your brother for four years
to know he's looked
to know he is locked up in a Russian
penal colony simply because you want to
use him for your own means I'm calling
on you right now to release Paul Whalen
Evan Gershwin immediately to let Paul
and Evan come home and to cease this
barbaric practice once and for all
colleagues while Russia may be
undermining the U.N Charter and this
institution the rest of us can and must
do better the U.N needs reform you've
heard that to support and maintain its
fundamental principles this body must
evolve to meet the 21st century as part
of that Evolution the security Council
needs to better reflect today's Global
realities we must find credible sensible
and politically viable paths to this end
and while we work to forge those paths
those of us on the security Council have
a duty to do more
to do better
as you all know in San Francisco last
year I announced six principles for
responsible behavior for Security
Council permanent members these were
standards we set for ourselves that we
welcome all to hold us to that we
encourage for other permanent members
colleagues the United States believes in
the United Nations and we believe in
this Charter
and that belief gives us faith that it
can be made better still
our response to Russia's flagrant
violations cannot be to abandon this
this institution's founding principles
instead we must recommit to the
principles of sovereignty
of territorial integrity
of peace and security
and use those principles as guideposts
as we strengthen the United Nations and
make it fit for the purposes of the 21st
Century
we must reform this institution and
support efforts such as the secretary
General's ambitious our common agenda
initiative to modernize the multilateral
system
we must not shirk our responsibilities
to address threats by the dprk to
International Peace and security
we must forcefully address the situation
in Sudan as we heard the call from the
Secretary General for peace and
assessation of hostilities we must use
our platform to call out aggression and
human rights violations wherever and
whenever we see them
we must renew our commitment to achieve
the sustainable development goals to
heal the climate to end poverty and
hunger
that is the brighter future we hope to
build
so we must rally behind this U.N Charter
take on shared Global challenges
seriously do everything in our power to
be better Neighbors
and together create a more peaceful more
prosperous world for us all thank you
as a courteous president I cannot budget
thank the representative of the United
States and I give the floor to the
representative of the United Kingdom
thank you
at the outset let me Echo these strong
concerns set out by the Secretary
General about the situation in Sudan
and the call for an immediate end to the
violence we have requested a council
meeting to address the situation
tomorrow
I join others in thanking the Secretary
General for his briefing
Minister lavrov has called this meeting
to share the Russian vision for the
future of multilateralism
we've seen what Russia's idea of
multilateralism means for the world
more than a year into Russia's
full-scale invasion of Ukraine
President Putin has brought unimaginable
suffering
to that country
while trampling on the U.N Charter
thousands of ukrainians have been killed
Millions have been displaced
and across the world
billions have faced rocketing commodity
prices and food insecurity
it's been
an unmitigated disaster for Russia too
neither Russia nor its neighbors feel
safer
trust in Russia's promises to other
states
and to its own people
is at a catastrophic low
again and again
the UN General Assembly has voted
overwhelmingly
to condemn Russia's invasion
President Putin can count the supporters
of his War
on one hand
Russia has severely damaged its
reputation in the International
Community
and now
President Putin is threatening to move
nuclear weapons into a neighboring state
for Russians
the world is getting smaller
many tens of thousands of Russian men
and women have been killed
hundreds of thousands have been
mobilized against their will
millions are fleeing the country to
escape the draft
independent journalists have been
arrested
Free Speech has been crushed
Russia's economy is shrinking
its Army is in disarray
reliant on Wagner an unaccountable
mercenary group
whose existence was denied a year ago
but who now offers your foreign Ministry
advice on your Security Council
presidency
a Russian generation has lost its future
and the Russian government can't even
explain why
Russia's justifications for the war
defeating Nazis and defending against
bio weapons
are obvious falsehoods
Russia's claims to Ukraine's territory
we'll never be recognized
for all of Minister lavrov's claims
about effective multilateralism
I see nothing effective or multilateral
about Russia's foreign policy
multilateral institutions can and should
evolve the security Council included
and with the UK supports reforms to make
it more effective and representative
change must be underpinned by respect
for the basic principles of the charter
above all
the principles of sovereignty and
territorial integrity
the world also needs a free and safe
Ukraine
that can return to supplying the world
with food
the UK will continue to stand together
with Ukraine as it lawfully defends
itself
foreign minister lavrov claims he is as
interested in ending the conflict as
soon as possible
to do so
Russia must immediately remove its
troops from all Ukrainian territory
thank you
I I invited the representative of the
People's Republic of Republic of China
to take the floor
thank you Mr President
Mr President
I'm honored to speak as the
representative of Mr qingham State
counselor and foreign minister of China
thanks Russia as president of the
security Council for this month for its
initiative to convene this open debate
and welcomes foreign minister lavrov's
presiding over this meeting I also thank
Secretary General guterres
for
his briefing
I also agree
with
his assessment on the current challenges
we are facing
the world is standing at a historic
Crossroads now the humanity is facing
unprecedented Global challenges acts of
her Germany and Bully are causing
colossal harm to the world block
politics are creating huge divisions and
confrontations it has become all the
more urgent and important to uphold the
U.N Charter
what is most needed now is for all
countries to practice genuine
multilateralism strength and unity under
the banner of the United Nations enhance
the effectiveness of the global
governance system achieve common
security promote common development and
open up a common future
first the authority of the U.N Charter
must be firmly safeguarded
the U.N Charter is the Cornerstone of
the post-war International order
the principles of respecting sovereignty
and territory Integrity non-interference
of internal affairs of other countries
as a stipulated in the charter have
become the basic Norms governing modern
international relations the problems
that have arising in the world today are
not because Jew and Charter has become
obsolete but because its purposes and
principles have not been effectively
implemented
the security and well-being of present
and future generations of mankind still
depend on the continued promotion of the
spirit of the charter and on the
preservation of the status and role of
the United Nations
to safeguard the authority and
effectiveness of the charter we should
not just do it in words but also in
these
we must not just have others do it but
start with oneself
we must not be
half-hearted and do it selectively but
do it all the time consistently
we must not have exclusive Clubby
circles fabricate so-called
democracy confrontation and
authoritarian narratives and provoke
geopolitical confrontation but Advocate
dialogue and cooperation and insist on
extensive consultation joint
contribution and shared benefits and
resolve disputes by peaceful means
second we must firmly uphold the
international order underpinned by
international law
the world has only one order and that is
the international order underpinned by
international law
faced with a big change and Chaos in the
world today we must always be guided by
the principles and purposes of the UN
Charter and base ourselves on
international law in handling
International Affairs this was an
important guarantee for upholding
furnace and Justice addressing Global
challenges and safeguarding the
sovereignty security and development
interests of all countries we oppose
some countries distorting the meaning of
international law imposing its own will
on the International Community
packaging it into the so-called
rules-based International order and
wantonly violating the legitimate rights
of other countries in violation of rule
of law international rule of law we also
oppose the belittling of international
agreements whether it is arbitrarily
tearing them up or having double
standards
there is no credibility to speak of in
this regard if a major power arbitrarily
turns important treaties and agreements
that bear on International Peace and
security into that ladder then not only
will international law be eroded by the
world will have no peace at all
in this regard
the relevant country should earnestly
reflect its action
third
it is necessary to ensure equal
participation of all countries in
international Affairs the International
System with the UN at its core carries
the comment expectations of the world's
peoples and should serve the interests
of all countries the United Nations
cannot
and should not serve the interests of
only some countries or even a few
countries
it is unreasonable for citizens of one
country to had some specialized U.N
agencies and international financial
institutions on a long term or even
permanent basis
the big change of the world is
accelerating the multi-polar world is
becoming a reality the pace of democracy
in international relations must also
keep up to truly reflect equality and
enhance the equity and effectiveness of
multilateralism
developing countries and African
countries in particular
deserve to play a greater role in the
United Nations
the right of developing countries to
participation and decision making must
be insured
we support the initiative of Secretary
General guterres to reform the
international financial institutions and
we must act immediately
to improve the global governance system
fourth
unilateral sanctions that violate
international law must be resisted
unilateral sanctions indiscriminately
imposed by the United States and other
countries outside the council mandate
are entirely for maintaining their
hegemony Technological monopoly and
ideology their practice has no legal
basis this stands in sharp contrast to
the development and progress of the
world
unilateral sanctions are like a
rampaging monster
constantly creating and aggravating
humanitarian crisis violating the basic
rights of women and children hindering
the development and progress of
countries especially small and
medium-sized countries and causing
immense damage to the Harmony and
stability of international relations
what is of Greater concern is that
unilateral sanctions often in the name
of upholding international law and
implementing Council resolutions have
subjected the United Nations to
unfounded Acquisitions and weakened its
Authority for multilateralism we once
again urge the relevant countries
to immediately stop unilateral sanctions
and call on the International Community
and all countries to uphold fairness and
Justice and Independence and jointly
resist and counteract such illegal Acts
Mr President as a prominent member of
the security Council and the responsible
large country China adheres to January
multilateralism all the time in
complying with the purposes and
principles of the U.N Charter and in
complying with international law and
basic Norms governing international
relations China has the best record
president XI jinping's concept of
building a community with a short future
for mankind represents a fundamental
direction for resolving key challenges
and difficulties of the world today
China will vigorously promote and
Implement a global development
initiative Global Security initiative
and Global civilization initiative
comprehensively promote Chinese
modernization participate in the work of
the United Nations on all fronts and
make our contribution to the promotion
of international solidarity and
cooperation in jointly addressing
challenges
and in safeguarding the common values of
mankind
in the face of a world with intertwined
change and turmoil China will move
firmly in the right direction I thank
you Mr President
I thank the representative of the
beautiful problem
of Japan
Mr President at the outset I would like
to make this clear
multi-rateralism is at the very heart of
the United Nations there may be
different views on multirotism but I
hope that this open debate is not
intended to divide us rather than unite
us
no single member states can solve
today's Global challenges alone we need
a collective multiraptor response
much rotarism functions only when member
states work together based on Mutual
trust and cooperation consistent with
the purposes and principles of the
United Nations
it is an irony even a tragedy that the
Russian Federation a permanent member of
the security Council
continues its unilateral aggression
against Ukraine while hosting
an open debate on effective maltra
terrorism through the defense of the
principle of the U.N Charter on the very
International Day of multiraptorism and
diplomacy for peace
the unprovoked ongoing aggression by
Russia is nothing but outright Defiance
of the principle of the U.N Charter
the Relentless youth will threat to the
use of of the veto that has accompanied
this aggression has blocked the security
Council from making decisions paralyzing
and discarding the council when the
world needs it most to fulfill its
responsibility
Russia must first and foremost withdraw
all its troops and equipment from the
territory of Ukraine within its
International recognized borders
immediately and unconditionally
there has been the repeated demand of
the general assembly supported by 141
votes the overwhelming majority of the
member states
let me be clear any attempt to
unilaterally change a peacefully
established status of territories by
force of a caution should not be
tolerated anywhere in the world
also any statement to deny sovereignty
Independence and territorial Integrity
of Ukraine neighboring countries or any
other member State should not be
tolerated especially those by a
permanent member of this Council
the concept note of this open debate
circulated by Russia does not measure a
single word regarding Ukraine nor the
aggression against it
and instead just criticizes many other
past crises and invasions
there's no country with a Flawless
historical record all of us should scary
face that reality and be humble about it
but having said that it would be a
misuse and politicization of the word
multirutterism if it was solely meant to
criticize selectively chosen uniritary
actions of other countries
such a narrative in an attempt to Garner
support for one's own camp and the
legitimize one's actions would only
create further division Among Us
itself
revitalizing on the upholding
multiraptorism is more important than
ever
let us remind ourselves
this is not the first time we have been
divided every previous time we found a
path to overcome our divisions so let us
go back to the starting point
the purposes and the principles
enshrined in the U.N Charter and the
rule of law
and that means effective multirotism in
a world of diversity
this is why foreign minister yashi
reiterated his call for uniting for the
rule of law in this chamber in January
this is why Japan promotes a rule of law
in the security Council and Beyond
international law including the charter
and resolutions of the UN must be
respected abided by and implemented in
good fails by all
the U.N should continue to be the
bulwark of multira terrorism the
security Council should lead the work
not Amber it
we have to admit
the U.N has never been perfect
nonetheless we all need the U.N at the
core of malt rhetorism we have to
strengthen the function with the U.N
through reform to better reflect today
today's reality rather than that of
almost 80 years ago just as reminded by
the Secretary General in his briefings
it is long overdue since the world
leaders declared in one voice the
necessity of an early reform of the
security Council in 2005.
we should redouble our efforts to
achieve this goal at the earliest
Japan fully supports the secretary
General's initiative in our common
agenda and will continue to actively and
constructively participate in
discussions on the new agenda for peace
I hope that the ambitious
recommendations by the high level
Advisory Board will promote Library
discussions among the member states the
future of the United Nations and the
mouth-raterism depend upon us the member
states let us seize it together I thank
you
thank you I thank the representative of
Japan and I give the floor to the
representative of France
Mr President
built on the ruins of the second world
war the international multilateral order
which was created by the United Nations
Charter is an instrument for the
advancement of Peace it is based on such
principles as The Sovereign and quality
of States respect for international law
non-usive force and peaceful dispute
resolution these principles are
currently currently being flouted and
violated multilateralism means accepting
to comply with the rules which we
contributed collectively to drafting in
which we all chose to adhere to for the
preservation of International Peace and
security we must all respect our shared
Charter and the collective security
system which it has established which is
rooted in respectful for a law we recall
that the use of force except in the if
for legitimate defense is al-vard
however the for Russia the rules of a
law and principles undergirding
multiliteralism up here to no longer
apply Russia illegally used force in
Georgia in 2008 in Crimea and in donbass
in 2014 and for more than one year this
has been the case in Ukraine Russia has
been violating the core principles of
international order of the international
order
the sovereignty and territory Integrity
of Ukraine International a humanitarian
law by deliberately targeting and
systematically targeting civilians
international human rights law by the
deporting Ukrainian children and uh in
in engaging in other atrocities by
violating arms and bargos imposed by
Security Council by procuring drones
from Iran to indiscriminately bomb is a
Ukrainian civilian infrastructure
thereby also violating resolution
2231 which was adapted adopted in 2015
by the security Council general assembly
of the United Nations unequivocally
and by an overwhelming majority
condemned these violations of our
Charter the general assembly among other
things called on the Russian Federation
to end immediately its aggression to
withdraw its troops
if Russia genuinely wishes to uphold
multilateralism the Russian Federation
must respect the rules of international
order and the Russian Federation must
cease its violations of the charter if
Russia genuinely wishes to uphold
multilateralism it must end its war of
aggression which has Unleashed dire
consequences for both Ukraine and the
entire world if Russia genuinely wishes
to defend multilateralism they must
immediately withdraw troops from
Ukrainian soil if the Russian Federation
genuinely wishes to uphold
multilateralism they must initiate in
good faith in a Quest for Peace if
Russia genuinely wishes to uphold my
bilateralism then Russia must uphold the
rulings delivered by International
jurisdictions such as the international
court of justice which explicitly uh on
16 March 2022 issued a ruling if in the
face of other challenges including
security challenges health challenges
Environmental technological challenges
in the face of these challenges only
Collective responses can deliver
Solutions we need to address this crisis
in Sudan by upholding ambitious bold
multilateralism that protects the
interests of peoples and countries as
well as shared Heritage only the strict
respect for the principles of
international law and greater
cooperation can allow us to collectively
maintain International Peace and
security the law of the strongest
protects nobody we support International
institutions and the reform thereof to
adapt Global governance to reflect
present day challenges this is the case
for Security Council reform France
supports its expansion alongside Mexico
we have advanced an initiative proposing
that the five permanent members
collectively and voluntarily refrain
from usage of the veto in the case of
mass atrocities we urge all member
states to join this initiative which has
already secured the support of one 106
members
France has been contributing to the
considerations initiated by the
Secretary General for the future of our
planet and of our populations we have
contributed with the adoption of a new
agenda for peace France has also been
fully mobilized for the achievement of
the sustainable development goals we
remain a leader in terms of global
health for Education countering food and
security countering climate change
protection of land and sea biodiversity
alongside Costa Rica France will host
the United Nations conference on oceans
in 2025. we will also host in June in
Paris a summit to help secure a new
Global Financial compact in a context
where the Russian aggression in Ukraine
has seriously worsened the situation of
the most vulnerable countries and the
food insecurity there France has been
advancing gender equality including
through the woman peace and security
agenda of the security Council we
support the initiatives of the Secretary
General and France fully supports the
secretary General's recommendations
under common our common agenda which
calls for inclusive effective efficient
multilateralism in order to address the
most pressing challenges of humanity let
us continue to demand respect for our
shared rules let us continue to act for
International Peace and security let us
continue to protect and promote the
initiatives that are truly at the heart
of an advancement of International
Security and international law thank you
the representative of France and I'll
give a floor to the representative of
Malta thank you Excellency and I also
thank the Secretary General for sharing
his thoughts and insights with us today
over the years multilateral institutions
with the United Nations add their hearts
have promoted cooperation and brought
prosperity and stability
to make sure that our institutions
continue to serve us well we must
recommit to revitalized multilateral
system and uphold the fundamental
principles underpinning them especially
at a time when they are being undermined
this is needed to help us address the
unprecedented Global challenges we are
facing
enhance cooperation between multilateral
organizations at International and
Regional level with the UN at the core
of this work is especially important in
the areas of peace and security and
sustainable development
Malta is a strong advocate for the
Integrity Independence and functionality
of the U.N human rights mechanisms human
rights are Universal and indivisible
a transformational shift in global
governance to respond to Growing
inequalities is also needed
building a quality through
multilateralism requires the full equal
and meaningful participation of women to
promote gender transformative actions
and agreements
allow me to make two observations on the
concepts note circulated ahead of this
meeting
first it is important to highlight that
since the creation of United Nations the
world has been widely Guided by the UN
Charter and its fundamental principles
among which the principle of sovereignty
quality of states it is also worth
highlighting that according to the 1970
U.N declaration there is no conflict
between the principles of international
law as they are interrelated and each
principle should be constructed in the
context of the other principles
in this context we can never accept the
results of last year's illegal
referendums engineered by Russia as a
pretext for further violation of
Ukraine's Independence Sovereign
sovereignty and territorial Integrity we
can neither recognize the so-called
republics emerging from Russia's
illegitimate acts towards Ukraine and
their strive for interdependence or
strategic autonomy as indicated in this
concept note on the contrary such
actions contribute to the unraveling of
the rules-based order
second it is deeply worrying that the
Russian Federation a permanent member of
the security Council blatantly
disregarded the primary function of the
security Council to maintain
International Peace and security when it
launched its aggression against Ukraine
neither can we forget that this illegal
unprovoked and unjustified War generated
one of the worst Refugee crisis since
the second world war a global grain
shortage hundreds of thousands killed or
injured forced deportations of children
worldwide anxiety for nuclear disaster
and negatively impacted The credibility
of the council
on this occasion we once again urged the
Russian Federation to stop this war
withdraw its military forces from the
entire territory of Ukraine within its
International recognized borders and
turned to dialogue and diplomacy as a
tools which can bring stability to the
region
as an elected member of the security
Council Malta firmly believes in
applying in good faith the toolbox for
the peaceful settlement of disputes
contained in article 33 of the charter
in the same vein there is space for the
security Council to strengthen its
cooperation with the icj and the ICC
on Security Council reform Motors firm
in its conviction of the council needs
to reflect today's realities and
challenges to respond to true
multilateralism we underline the need
for the council to also be more
inclusive
Motors a strong support of the standing
mandate for a general assembly debate
when a veto is caused in the council in
the same vein we also fully support the
political Declaration on suspension of
veto Powers launched by France and
Mexico as well as the ACT code of
conducts
finally
unequivocally support sorry finally
motor vocably supports the UN secretary
General's key proposals traversing our
common agenda reports all the current
OCA related negotiations on progressing
the work of the organization enhancing
the constructive power of materialism as
well as the work of the high-level
Advisory board on effects of
multilateralism established by the U.N
Secretary General in March 2022
in preparation for the 2023 sustainable
development
growth Summit we underscore the need for
the International Community to take
stock of the progress we have achieved
so far and the gaps that remain while
engaging in intensive multilateral
efforts to bridge the implementation of
the sdgs back on track we also look
forward to the September 2024 Summit of
the future to our advancing ideas for
governance Arrangements in Glo in areas
of Global Commons I thank you
I think the representative of Malta and
I now give the floor to the
representative of Ecuador
president Mr President
I wish to begin by thanking the
Secretary General
of the United Nations Antonio guterres
for his briefing I also wish to
underscore the value of the focus given
to today's debate this debate
complements that organized by India in
December of 2022 entitled new
orientations for reformed
multilateralism
today's debate also complements the
meeting organized by China in May of
2021 on upholding multilateralism and
the U.N centered International System
furthermore it also complements the
debate convened by Vietnam in January
2020 on upholding the UN Charter for the
maintenance of International Peace and
Security in other words year after year
this chamber
Witnesses States agree on the need to
guarantee an effective multilateralism
through the defense of the United
Nations Charter the problem
is that since January 2020
instead of abating
conflicts have increased in number and
this in spite of the secretary General's
appeal for a global ceasefire
Mr President if we're going to talk
about multilateralism
well the time has come to go from words
to action
from discos to deed
following the tragic events which drove
humankind to two global conflagrations
with the United Nations Charter that
today we defend we enshrined the
principle of multilateralism never again
never again would a nation however
powerful it may be
never again would that Nation be able to
imperil the peace and security of
another Nation or of the world as a
whole simply because doing so would suit
its own interests or ambitions
the obligation and principle of the
peaceful settlement of disputes is a
pivotal one that was reiterated by this
very Security Council with the
presidential statement issued on the 6th
of May 2022 on
maintenance of peace and Security in
Ukraine
in only two weeks we will Mark the first
anniversary of that statement it has yet
to be implemented
another Central principle of the United
Nations Charter and one that is sacred
to States is the inviolability of
territorial Integrity as such we can say
that today's debate will have been
utterly pointless if once it closes
there is not one less conflict one less
war or one less invasion
Mr President what better result could
this debate have than a decision on the
part of your country to put an end to
its military aggression against Ukraine
in accordance with the decision handed
down by the international court of
justice on the 16th of March 2022 what
better Legacy could there be of your
presidency than if your government chose
to return to the path of peace and to
withdraw its occupying troops none of
the pretexts invoked to attack Ukraine
in violation of the U.N Charter has
legal Merit not one of them in this
chamber we've been told for example that
the invasion of Ukraine is a response to
a supposed phobia that exists of Russian
culture
we've been told that this invasion is a
response to a supposed Western
conspiracy to weaken Russia
we've been told that Russia is acting in
self-defense in response to anti-russian
policies imposed by Ukraine on certain
inhabitants
none of these arguments have any
grounding in the UN Charter it goes
without saying we must remember that the
charter is one indivisible and Universal
Mr President there is not a United
Nations Charter for the West
another for the East another further
north and another further south there is
not a United Nations Charter for Muslims
another for Christians and another for
Jews
we also can't talk about a charter for
Africa another for Europe or another for
America
and so on no Mr President the charter is
I repeat one charter it is indivisible
and Universal
how could we neglect to recognize
Russia's vast contribution including
that made by its major cultural
torchbearers Tolstoy does
but is there any way we could imagine
for even a minute that those cultural
envoys would be in agreement with the
death and pain that this absurd war is
inflicting upon millions of people
the concept note of this debate asks the
question how the can the United Nations
contribute to a smooth transition
to a fair and Equitable Global Order I
can assure you that war and violence
will in no way lead us to a fairer and
more Equitable order quite on the
contrary ladies and gentlemen global
Military expenditure exceeded two
trillion dollars in 2022 that alone
undermines the primary objectives of
multilateralism and the goals of this
organization peace security sustainable
development and human rights
where still is the fact that we need to
again recall that nuclear weapons have
no place in a law-based international
order they defy the existence of
humankind consequently we cannot talk
about effective multilateralism if we do
not move towards effective arms control
and disarmament
even article 26 of the UN Charter itself
refers to the least diversion for
armaments of the world human and
economic resources let us silence the
guns and honor the promise of peace that
we made in San Francisco let us honor
our commitment to living side by side as
good neighbors what morpheism anime is
there to multilateralism than treating
the world as a risk board or any board
game that was the world view of the
colonial powers of the 19th century the
world view of the fascist and Nazi
regimes of the 20th century regimes that
invaded and annexed other nations
subjugating them by force and at times
using shameful referenda
of legality to their actions this
practice is not only now incompatible
with the United Nations Charter it is
also ethically unacceptable
Ecuador cannot remain silent silent in
the face of this situation as such we
are Resolute in supporting Security
Council reform and the establishment of
a new agenda for peace but let us make
no mistake any institutional framework
however modern it may be any planning
tool however strategic and updated it is
Will
be nothing more than an empty shell if
they do not go hand in hand with a
behavior change on the part of states in
this regard the permanent members of the
security Council have the obligation to
demonstrate responsible leadership
leadership which understands and
respects the principle res communes
omnimum according to this principle The
Commons cannot be appropriated by one
individual because the commons are there
for the common benefit of the
International Community as was stated by
butrosgali only one power can impose
order on chaos that is the power of the
principles which
move Beyond changing opinions about what
is most suitable in the short term to
conclude I must recall that
multilateralium is not an end in itself
but rather a means however it is
something upon which women and girls in
Haiti Colombia Yemen Afghanistan Syria
or Somalia depend
we all depend on it and indeed all of
our Nations depend on it let us defend
the UN Charter let us do so by
practicing restraint and tolerance by
keeping and building peace as was
reminded by the Secretary General in his
report on our common agenda peace is a
global public good that we must protect
and manage thank you very much
I think the representative of Ecuador
and I now give the fourth representative
of Albania
thank you
let me start by thanking vsg for his
remarks and pay tribute to his stylish
efforts to his clear strong and always
principal position in favor of peace and
security and of multilateralism in
respect of the U.N Charter
colleagues
400 years ago
has said and I quote
hypocrisy is a tribute advice space to
the virtue
fast forward to this meeting and there
is a flagrant contradiction we find
ourselves in today
a permanent member of the security
Council has openly and defined it
disregard of the U.N Charter
that very country has knowingly
unwillingly transgressed every rule
commonly established regarding relations
between states
it has ignored Security Council
resolutions and its own International
commitments and yet it has chosen to
lecture the world about multilateralism
as we heard today
I could go on with general generalities
or repeat many important aspects
mentioned by colleagues around the table
but I prefer to recall the very simple
facts
Russia is waging an unjust unjustified
and illegal war of aggression against
Sovereign Nation it is questioning its
right to exist and has the audacity to
pretend to come to the rescue of
sovereign equality
the Russian military including the
Wagner group are committing horrible
crimes in Ukraine as documented by the
UN and Russia is pretending to defend
Universal values
Russian missiles are destroying
residential areas killing civilians
flattening schools health facilities and
other civil infrastructure to force an
entire country into submission and
Russia has come here to share its views
about friendly relations and cooperation
among states
if it weren't for the thousands of
innocent victims the millions forcefully
displaced for the countless children
stripped of their dreams and deprived of
their childhood for the immense pain of
those tortured of women raped and
families torn apart it would have been a
parody something the Monty Python would
have entitled preserving the U.N Charter
the Russian style shredded and store it
Six Feet Under
unfortunately this isn't a parody and we
cannot laugh
what has happened in Ukraine is a
tragedy a man-made catastrophe with
serious security repercussions in Europe
and detrimental Ripple effects around
the world
it represents the country of everything
we stand for and everything that gets us
together here
therefore no peace-loving Nation will
buy an artificial parallel reality
engineer to transform the aggressor into
a defender of the U.N Charter the
arsonist into a firefighter and the
warmonger into a peacemaker
this is the real issue and this is what
we think we should be talking about
especially on this day
colleagues
the ongoing the ongoing war in Ukraine
and the current Global reality pause the
fundamental question of multilateralism
its future and our ability to defend it
almost eight decades have clearly shown
that multilateralism has been and
remains indispensable to promoting peace
and stability uphold the rule of law
promote and protect human rights
today we need multilateralism more than
ever because we know that Global
challenges require Global solutions that
we can achieve more by working together
rather than by pursuing our interest
individually no country alone whatever
its size and wealth will be able to deal
successfully climate change
transnational terrorism or future
pandemics
this requires a genuine commitment to
International cooperation diplomacy and
compromise and the firm recognition that
no country can achieve its goals at the
expense of the others this requires
defending and standing by what we have
agreed respecting International
commitments and denouncing those who
abuse and deform its Spirit under the
disguise of Defending it
colleagues the U.N needs reform to
strengthen it make it more efficient
more resultative not to undo it we do
not want the world fueled by
resuscitated Imperial appetites a world
fragmented by new rivalries instead of
one United in purpose
the number of polls will be meaningless
and ridiculous if we fail to address the
fundamental challenges posed by climate
change and environmental deterioration
the union general assembly has confirmed
several times that it will not accept
the future where might dictates the
right that it will not be trolled by
cynical semantics where an aggression is
labeled Special Operation and crimes are
disguised as special care
yes let's call the speed of spade since
hypocrisy is nothing more than the
audacity to preach Integrity through
depravity
and unfortunately there was a ton of it
from Russia Today in a toxic mixture of
everything that fits it propaganda
in particular it has become a Russian
Obsession to refer to the Republic of
Kosovo a country recognized by more than
half of the U.N to justify its unlawful
actions in Georgia in 2008 in Ukraine
since 2014 which as we all know is going
on to this hour
the international court of justice has
ruled that the independence of crossover
is in accordance with international law
the same icj has asked for Russia to
stop its War therefore there is nothing
that sounds hollower than the desperate
effort to justify the unjustifiable and
its attempt to hide behind the
unacceptable
as we know as we know you cannot hide
the sun with the finger and today once
more we did not hear anything on the key
issue under which article of the UN
Charter has Russia attacked its neighbor
and has annexed by force parts parts of
its territory
colleagues if we want to maintain the
U.N as the Cornerstone of the
multilateral world we need to show
respect for each other not contempt we
need to show solidarity no threats we
need to show diplomas to choose
diplomacy and Foster dialogue not wage
war we need to work together abide by
our commitments and we need Justice
through accountability for crimes
committed and for the perpetrators to be
held to account
in today's terms of urgency this means
that Russia must end its War withdraw
its troops from Ukraine and respect its
sovereignty and its territorial
Integrity within the internationally
recognized borders and I thank you
I think Albania
and I now give the floor to those
members of the
organization who wish to take the floor
during today's open debate and the first
to take the floor I give the is a
representative of Mr Gerardo Pena Del
portal a first Deputy Minister of
Foreign Affairs of Cuba you have the
floor sir
thank you very much indeed Mr President
Mr President
we endorse these statements made that
will rather shortly be made by the chair
of the coordinating Bureau of the
non-aligned movement the representative
of Azerbaijan we also align ourselves
with the statement to be made by
Venezuela on behalf of the group of
friends in defense of the UN Charter we
welcome here among us today the presence
of the minister for foreign affairs of
the Russian Federation as president of
the security Council we also recognize
the deputy Minister we welcome the
convening of this open debate as we Mark
the international day of
multilateralism and diplomacy for peace
this was an initiative promoted within
the general assembly of the United
Nations by the sister bolivarian
Republic of Venezuela when it held the
chairmanship of the non-aligned movement
between 2016 and 2019
Mr President in the currently complex
landscape marked by an escalation of
tensions and new forms of domination and
hegemony we are seeing threats to
International Peace and security grow
and we're seeing the gradual weakening
of multilateralism
the global multi-dimensional crisis that
we're currently witnessing has been
rendered by rendered more acute by the
covid-19 pandemic it is dealing a
heavier blow to the countries of the
South and this is a result of the unjust
and unsustainable prevailing
International order we've seen
inequalities worsen social
marginalization heightened and poverty
grow more severe
Wars are abounding non-conventional Wars
are intensifying and we're seeing the
arms race continue at Breakneck speed
attempts have been made to reimpose a
unipolar order this is being done by
Nations showing blatant disregard for
international treaties and by their
increasing the application of unilateral
coercive measures and these join other
frequent violations of the United
Nations Charter and international law
these violations undermine the peaceful
coexistence of nations in the face of
this grave reality we reaffirm the need
to pull efforts to strengthen
multilateralism International
cooperation and solidarity to tackle
common challenges there is an urgent
need to usher in wholesale
transformations of the United Nations
organization in such a way as to allow
us to move towards a international
Democratic order which is just Equitable
and which respects the Sovereign
inequality of states and this for the
benefit of present and future
Generations
we must promote a culture of Peace one
which guarantees the security and
well-being of our Nations we must
Revitalize and strengthen the role of
the UN General Assembly without there
being any interference of
with without the security Council rather
interfering in its work there is an
overriding need to reform the security
Council and to render it a more
transparent inclusive Democratic and
representative body Mr President
multilateralism and absolute respect for
the purposes and principles of the UN
Charter and international law are the
way in which we can guarantee the
peaceful coexistence of Nations and the
only way that we can guarantee
International Peace and security and the
only way that we can find lasting
solutions to systemic problems we must
immediately see the cessation of
unilateral coercive measures and the
establishment of a spurious and
arbitrary lists such as that of states
which supposedly sponsor terrorism these
lists were encounter to international
law
the world needs solidarity cooperation
and mutual respect not blockades nor
sanctions Cuba will continue to defend
staunchly and consistently the charter
of the United Nations and international
law we will remain committed to the
tenets of the Proclamation of Latin
America and the Caribbean as a zone of
peace with strict adherence to these
principles we reaffirm our commitment to
multilateralism and to the preservation
of International Peace and security
thank you very much
into Mr Gerardo Pena portal and I give
the floor to the representative of
Mexico
thank you Mr President
the convening of this debate on
effective multilateralism is Timely
provided that we tackle this issue in a
comprehensive fashion we are grateful to
the Secretary General for his Lucid
diagnosis of the problems we Face Mexico
is convinced of the importance of
multilateralism to address the common
problems of humankind
however for this multilateralism to be
effective States absolutely must uphold
their obligations with strict respect
for the rule of law it is only in this
way that we will be able to deploy the
multilateral mechanisms required to
avoid a situation where we see the claps
of the international order or to avoid
this order only being restored once it
has clapped collapsed as such the
current challenges jeopardizing the
effectiveness of multilateralism are
huge constant violations of the UN
Charter constant violations of the
security council's resolutions and
constant violations of the obligations
emanating from political commitments and
a range of treaties in Peril
International Peace and security within
a highly volatile Arena
regarding violations of the charter
The Invasion by one sovereign country of
any other constitutes a flagrant
violation of Article 2 paragraph 4 of
the charter and constitutes an act of
aggression pursuant to resolution 3314
of the general assembly
moreover we reiterate our concern too at
the frequent invocations of self-defense
against non-state actors this is an
abusive use of article 51 of the charter
Mr President we are currently facing the
collapse of certain collective security
systems on which our organization is
built indeed The Lion's Share of the
world order is built on these systems
There Is frequent non-compliance with
decisions of the security Council and
this non-compliance doesn't produce any
great consequences that fact undermines
the security council's Authority and its
credibility in the eyes of the
International Community and in the eyes
of the un's peoples regarding
non-compliance with International
treaties will refer to only one example
which has historically been a source of
great concern for Mexico
more than 50 years of elapse since the
entry into force of the npt
in that time the commitments entered
into by nuclear weapons dates pursuant
to its article
six have not been complied with far from
it something similar is occurring with
political commitments in terms of small
arms and like weapons for example this
is an issue of great interest for many
countries including my own it is
regrettable that we continue to fail to
adopt effective measures to prevent
compact combat and eradicate the illicit
trafficking of small arms alike weapons
some of the primary producers of these
weapons allow or tolerate the
proliferation or deviation of these
weapons and that is a great Catalyst for
conflicts around the world
as therefore effective multilateralism
should take measures to contain and
reverse situations such as these
unfortunately this is difficult to
achieve particularly in terms of peace
and International Security when this
council is paralyzed by a veto being
used by a small number able to Halt the
international community's action
multilateral legal bodies continue to
have a limited scope consequently we
need to achieve the universality of the
Rome statute which created the
international criminal court we need to
make progress with the acceptance of the
icj's jurisdiction reality is proving to
be quite different after almost 80 years
less than half of the UN member states
accept the icjs jurisdiction in
conclusion
discussions such as that we're having
today are necessary and timely however
the challenges facing multilateralism
greatly
limit our organization preventive
diplomacy and maybe mediation this has
already been said must be genuine
options which go hand in hand with the
vital reform of the security Council if
we really do wish to move towards a more
effective multilateralism as such Mexico
tables a proposal for a reform of the
security Council which is comprehensive
the goal of this proposal is to lend
momentum to negotiations underway within
the general assembly thank you
I thank the representative of Mexico and
I wish to remind all distinguished
speakers of the request to limit the
length of their statements to four
minutes to ensure that the security
Council uh can carry out its work
expeditiously I now give the floor to
the representative of the Islamic
Republic of Iran
in the name of God the compassionate the
mercy food Mr President
you acknowledge Russia presidency for
convening this important and timely open
debate and we thank Minister lavrov and
the Secretary General for their
insightful views and believing for
reaffirming the significance of
multilateralism Mr President
multilateralism has been recognized as a
well-established approach to addressing
Global challenges and effective
multilateralism operating within the
framework of the U.N Charter is
essential for ensuring International
Peace and security
achieving this requires a strong
commitment to upholding international
law promoting transparency and
accountability and adhering to the
principles outlined in the U.N Charter
the U.N Charter established a
comprehensive work of principles and
Norms that member states might adhere
to in their relations with one another
these principles include peaceful
dispute resolution respect for
sovereignty and territorial Integrity
non-interference in Internal Affairs the
hero prohibition of the use of force and
the promotion of Human Rights and
fundamental freedoms
by abiding by these principles member
states can promote a stable and secure
International legal order that benefit
All Nations and peoples in the meantime
multilateralism must ensure the active
participation of all Nations regardless
of their size wealth or political
orientation
the exclusion of any country undermines
the principle of inclusiveness and may
result in biased outcomes
all countries especially those directly
affected by decisions made through
multilateral multilateral mechanism
should have an equal opportunity to
participate contribute and to be healed
in the decision-making processes Mr
President excellencies the integrity and
effectiveness of multilateralism are
undermined by the abuse of human systems
and selective application of
international law as well as the use of
unilateralism which poses a serious
threat to International cooperation
peace and security
unilateral causative measures including
the exploratorial application represent
a concerning example of harmful
Universal acts that run counter to the
fundamental principles of international
law the U.N Charter and basic human
rights these illegal measures how
far-reaching humanitarian consequences
and can undermine diplomatic Affairs
aimed at resolved dispute and promoting
cooperation within this context the
United States of electoral withdrawal
from the gcpoa the imposition of illegal
immature sanction on Iran is coercion of
the other countries to engage in these
illegal actions and Defiance of
international court of justice order are
striking as examples of how much harmful
industrial acts violate the U.N Charter
undermine the U.N systems and treating
the multilateralism
in this recent judgment on 13 March 2023
in the case of concerning certain
Iranian assessed International court of
justice has declared that the United
States has violated its International
obligations to the Iranian people by
imposing industrial sanctions that are
deemed illegal on their international
law the icg's ruling is final and
binding requiring the U.S to comply with
this decision in conclusion Mr President
collaboration should be the Cornerstone
of multilateralism rather than
confrontation collaborative approach
Foster trust build consensus and promote
sustainable solution to Global
challenges through collaborative problem
solving and engagement with all parties
must literalize them can effectively
address the challenges facing our war
today in this context diplomacy dialogue
and negotiation should be the preferred
means for resolving this dispute among
memory States I thank you Mr President
I thank the representative of the
Islamic Republic of Iran and I now
invite the representative of Egypt to
take the floor
Mr minister
we wish to congratulate you on your
presidency of the security Council this
month of April and for we commend you
for the choice of the theme for today's
meeting this is a theme which is a
Paramount importance for Egypt in the
light of the challenges which our world
has been encountering
it is incumbent upon us to work towards
surmounting these challenges which has
been affecting developing States
specifically African States today we are
discussing a reinforcement of effective
multilateralism this needs to be more
effective through the wind within the
United Nations system and in this regard
is incumbent upon us to base ourselves
on the principles of the United Nations
Charter which was the founding document
for the United Nations let us recall a
few historic elements first and foremost
the signing of the charter in 1945. this
was a turning point in the history of
humanity the International Community
took an informed decision to base
international relations on cooperation
on consensus on Justice on peace on
Peaceful coexistence
on collective security on equality in
terms of sovereignty and on a
non-interference Egypt is among the
founding nations of the organization
Egypt has also played a key role in the
creation of other International
organizations and Regional organizations
specifically the African Unity
organization known today as the African
Union as well as the league of Arab
states the organization of Islamic
conference which is now known as the OIC
organization of Islamic cooperation as
well as we have contributed to a number
of initiatives of regional groups and
coalitions and inter-regional groups of
coalitions such as g77 plus China as
well as a non-aligned movement 75 years
have elapsed since the Inception of our
organization and we have observed a
number of alarming practices first and
foremost
the setbacks and backsliding and a
number of key principles which were at
the heart of the creation of our
organization there have been attempts at
interference in Internal Affairs of
States under under various fallacious
pretexts second the monopolization by
certain countries specifically certain
major Powers the monopolization of
decision making without consultations
with states in the concerned regions
specifically African States
and in this regard let us recall the
develop the evolutions in Africa that
have been observed over the past seven
decades these developments mean that
African States opinions need to be taken
on board third there has been double
standards and a number of files and
these have affected political
relationships as well as links and ties
and relationships among other countries
fourth attempts by certain states to
politicize International forum and this
has undermined the ability of these fora
to act and this has undermined
International multilateralism
specifically through international trade
as part of development and countering
climate change fifth
the attempt by a sum to downplay the
role of states by attributing greater
importance to the actions of non-state
actors this is particularly alarming if
a number of non-state actors have an
opportunity to play a positive role in
some files this does not mean that they
can replace States or to engage in or to
to compete with States Mr President
uh overall reform of the International
multilateral System needs to be based on
the following number one all states need
to be convinced of the need for peaceful
coexistence based on Justice and
equality to achieve this there is a need
to revert back to the principles of the
charter of the United Nations to counter
the various challenges which we
currently face two there's a need for
reform of global economic governance
system within which there are the
Bretton Woods institutions
we need this reform in order to surmount
the challenges of climate change and
food security
on the basis of an initiative which was
submitted by Egypt during cope 27 and
chairman Sheikh and on the basis of the
need to reform the multilateral trade
system which presently has been
affecting Economic Development
sustainable Economic Development three
we need to re-examine the collective
security system
by
allowing various regions to play their
role and by reforming the security
Council by correcting the historic
Injustice For Africa based on the
elsewhere hini consensus as well as the
Seer declaration the security Council
also needs to improve its working
methods and to enhance coordination and
cooperation with the regional mechanisms
specifically African mechanisms to find
African solutions to African problems Mr
President we have been proactively
engaged in dialogue Dialogue on the
future of our organization and
we have been closely following the
various proposals submitted by Secretary
General specifically in the lead-up to
the summit for the future as well as
through our common agenda and the new
agenda for peace we believe that today's
meeting should grant us an opportunity
to seize these various opportunities to
move forward thank you Mr President I
thank the representative of Egypt and I
now give the floor to the representative
of Pakistan
[Music]
thank you Mr President
Mr President uh first of all let me say
it's a profound pleasure personally for
me to see you preside over the this
meeting of the security Council
the Pakistan delegation also thanks you
and the Russian presidency for
organizing this important debate on
International Security and effective
multilateralism
we also thank the Secretary General for
his important briefing
Mr President today International Peace
and security
confront multiple threats arising from
violations of the principles of the U.N
Charter
great power rivalries A Renewed Global
arms race
proliferating conflicts and disputes
spreading terrorism hate and
islamophobia
organized crime
Rising poverty and growing climate
impacts
we believe that these
multi-dimensional and Global challenges
can be overcome
only through multilateral cooperation
we reject a unipolar
bipolar or even a so-called multi-polar
world if it is dominated by a few large
and powerful states
such an order would be contrary to the
principle of sovereign equality of
states
we seek effective multilateralism a
multilateral order constructed on the
basis of the principles and purposes of
the U.N Charter One in which each member
state has an equal voice and an equal
stake
at the same time we must express our
concern at some new Concepts advanced in
some of our discussions within the
United Nations such as
multi-stakeholder and networked
multilateralism
these Concepts too
are contrary to the U.N Charter which
envisages an International System
composed of equal and Sovereign member
states
Mr President effective multilateralism
can address the current and emerging
threats to International Peace and
security
a critical part of this endeavor must be
to promote Universal and consistent
respect for the fundamental principles
of the U.N Charter by all states
irrespective of their size power and
influence
to this end the U.N Secretary General
should prepare an annual review
of situations on the security council's
agenda where the Charter's principles
and its resolutions are and the
resolutions of the security Council are
being violated or remain unimplemented
the security Council must take bold
decisions to secure the compliance by
states with the Charter's principles and
its own resolutions and decisions the
council has various means available to
it under the charter to secure such
compliance
the Secretary General has rightly
mentioned decolonization as a major
achievement of the United Nations
yet a prime illustration
of the derogation from the charter and
the security council's resolutions
is the situation in Indian occupied
Jammu and Kashmir where the exercise of
the right of self-determination by the
kashmiri people
prescribed by the security Council has
been subverted and suppressed by India
through seven decades of force and fraud
another is the situation in occupied
Palestine
protestations of commitments to the U.N
Charter
ring Hollow
when no action is taken to redress these
blatant violations of the U.N Charter
and resolutions of the security Council
on two issues which have remained on the
agenda of the security Council for the
last 75 years
secondly Mr president if the world is to
avoid Global catastrophe
it is now essential to redress the
rising tensions between the major
military powers
we hope that a sincere effort will be
made to end the war in Ukraine on the
basis of the charter and international
agreements
we hope that tensions will not be
further provoked in Asia
we are concerned at the expansion of
military alliances and the escalation of
military expenditures and capabilities
these developments also threaten peace
and stability in South Asia and the
Indian Ocean
Mr President the summit of the future
next year
should reaffirm the solemn commitment
especially by the militarily significant
States
to refrain from the use or threat of use
of force
respect the U.N Charter's principles
Implement Security Council resolutions
restrained military expenditures and
provocative deployments and estew
Military blocks and alliances
Mr President Rising Global tensions have
undermined the entire edifice of arms
control and disarmament and uncontrolled
arms race which now encompasses several
new weapons and new domains of
competition
will sooner or later lead to a
disastrous conflict involving States
armed to the teeth with conventional and
nuclear weapons the United Nations can
and should take the lead in Reviving The
process of arms control and disarmament
based on the consensus achieved at the
1978 first special session on
disarmament
whose Central principles were equal
security for all states ensuring
National Security at the lowest possible
level of armaments and the preservation
of military balance and mutual restraint
at the global and Regional level
we must also Outlaw dangerous military
doctrines especially the presumption
that conventional Wars can be fought
between nuclear armed states without
fear of nuclear escalation
Mr President the U.N security Council
the general assembly and the Secretary
General can do much more to promote the
peaceful settlement of disputes through
the multiple modalities available under
the chapters 6 7 and 8 of the charter
the agenda for peace mentioned by the
Secretary General must also address the
fundamental causes of conflict including
poverty and hunger foreign occupation
and oppression Injustice human rights
violations and environmental and climate
impacts
Mr President finally effective
multilateralism can only be built on the
foundations of strong International
institutions the security Council should
be enlarged and become more
representative accountable Democratic
transparent and effective it should not
become an enlarged Club of the large and
powerful states
however a reformed Security Council in
itself offers no Panacea to ensure
effective multilateralism it must be
accompanied by fully utilizing the
considerable potential of the general
assembly the activation of the un's
disarmament machinery and most
critically the reform and
democratization of the Bretton Woods
institutions Mr President effective
multilateralism in short must be
comprehensive inclusive and Equitable
Pakistan will work assiduously to
promote such effective multilateralism
including in the preparations for the
summit of the future next year I thank
you Mr Speaker
I think the representative of Pakistan
and I now invite the representative of
the Philippines to take the floor
thank you Mr President
I would like to thank your Excellency
Sergey lavrov Minister of Foreign
Affairs of the Russian Federation for
convening today's Security Council open
debate on multilateralism
I would also like to thank the Secretary
General for his briefing
uh president Marcos Ferdinand R Marcos
Jr had stated that and I quote amidst
challenging Global Tides an important
ballast stabilizes our common vessel
that is our open inclusive and
rules-based international order
that is governed by international law
and informed by the principles of equity
and of Justice close quotes
with that in mind Ms proud founding
member of the United Nations
the Philippines reaffirms its commitment
to the Charter of the United Nations its
principles and firm adherence to the
rule of law among nations
we reject any attempt to deny or
redefine our common understanding of
these principles
The Landmark 1970 declaration principles
of international law concerning friendly
relations among states represents our
common understanding of these principles
in multilateral lateralism international
and international law is a great
equalizer
the Philippines for its part has exerted
utmost efforts to reinforce the
predictability and stability of
international law in addressing
challenges to peace and security
international law provides a strong
basis for dialogue and consensus in
addressing differences
with the 1982 U.N convention on the law
of the sea we provided an example of how
States should resolve their differences
through reason and through right
resorting to Peaceful settlement of
international disputes through
arbitration and credible and competent
International tribunals plays a key role
in the interpretation of international
norms
and should not be seen as an unfriendly
act among civilized Nations
defending the charter means adherence to
its fundamental principles
compliance with International tribunals
as well as active engagement with the UN
processes including through the special
committee on the charter of the United
Nations to ensure constructive outcomes
I take this opportunity to highlight the
Manila declaration which reaffirms
fundamental principles of the U.N
Charter
among others the obligation of all
states to settle their international
disputes by peaceful means in such a
manner that International Peace and
security
and Justice are not endangered
as an initiative of non-aligned
countries the Manila declaration remains
as relevant as ever as we confront
complex interrelated challenges to the
rule of law and the U.N Charter
including in the context of the new
agenda for peace
fundamental to an effective multiple
lateralism is an inclusive transparent
reformed and representative Security
Council
a reformed Council must be able to
respond decisively and swiftly to 21st
century challenges and threats to
International Peace and security
it should highlight improving work
improved working methods aimed at
greater participation of non-members
it also involves enhanced consultations
mechanism between the security Council
and Regional groups and sub-brew
subgroups
I conclude by underscoring that for the
Philippines a people-centered
multilateralism must strive as a unifier
and that's a platform for inclusion and
empowerment of Nations and their
citizens
people-centered multilateralism must be
a constant even as we continue to face
Global challenges amidst geopolitical
tensions and strategic competitions
multilateralism will be effective if we
adhere to the principles that we deeply
cherish
non-aggression non-interference
peaceful coexistence respect for
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and equality and mutual benefits thank
you Mr President
I think the representative of the
Philippine
invite the representative of the Syrian
Arab Republic to take the floor is
thank you Mr President first of all I
would like to welcome his Excellency
Minister Sergey labrove the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs of the Russian
Federation and his presidency of this
very important meeting also you would
like to thank the Russian Federation
for holding this important meeting that
is timely and substantive first of all
we would like to align ourselves with
the statement of Azerbaijan on behalf of
the unaligned movement and the statement
of Venezuela on behalf of the group of
friends in defense of the charter Mr
President
the United Nations has been since its
Inception 80 years ago the face of
multilateralism the United Nations has
directly contributed to Peaceful
settlement of conflicts decolonization
peacekeeping and peace building
promoting
the efforts
towards the non-proliferation of weapons
of mass destruction and
counter-terrorism the charter of the
United Nations is very clearly
categorized and in includes specific
benchmarks regarding the mandates of the
main bodies namely the general assembly
the security Council and the other
organs established by virtue of the
charter the charter also has a number of
Provisions related to the mechanisms and
mandates of all those bodies which are
ideally
mentioned thus we have to abide by the
mandates of those bodies and those
bodies should be discharging their
mandates without encroachment on the
mandates of other
organs and without exceeding their
mandate this also should avoid any chaos
or competition amongst those bodies
whether at the level of decision making
or even crisis management and management
of international conflicts the
mechanisms and methods of work of the
United Nations have significantly
affected
the development of friendly relations
between member states and
those mechanisms have equally been
influenced by the arising challenges
imposed by the changing real reality of
international relations this calls for
continuous and comprehensive review of
those methods of work and mechanisms in
terms of substance and procedures the
Main
rules
of
the work of the United Nations is based
on multilateralism especially when it
comes to a conflict settlement
peacefully as well as the main
principles of equality in sovereignty
economic operation and development in
order for us to achieve this objective
all member states should abide by the
Mainstays of the United Nations may be
reflected in its Charter in addition to
the provisions of the international law
as well as the established Norms of
international relations meanwhile we
have to avoid using
using methods or using terminology
that are not consensual especially the
term of rules-based system
the development and Improvement of the
work of the main bodies of the United
Nations
requires more objectivity
and wise planning
as regards the items that the items on
the agenda of those organs
recently the general assembly has
witnessed the remarkable increase in the
number of items on its agenda and there
is an unprecedented increase in the
number of
unconsensual resolutions and in many
cases
voting a vote is required
notwithstanding
notwithstanding the differences on the
substance and procedures of those
resolutions the security Council has
also witnessed severe polarization
especially on the part of certain
permanent members by way of confusing
priorities in their and diverse who
diverted the security Council away from
its main mandate which is the
maintenance of International Peace and
Security in order to serve their own
destructive agendas Mr President the
multilateral system incarnated by the
United Nations has faced during the last
two decades staggering challenges
when addressing a number of a political
economic and social crises this was
manifest in the debacle of preventing
the American invasion of Iraq in 2003
and the inability to put an end to the
tragedy of the Palestinian people who
language under the Yoke of the Israeli
occupation for decades
and addressing the increasing terrorist
threats and the outbreak of pandemics
and diseases in addition to exacerbation
of a humanitarian suffering due to
Poverty hunger and thirst preserving
real multilateralism requires reforming
the current structures chiefly amongst
which expanding the security Council to
be truly representative of the new
political reality and also to reform the
international financial institutions
such as such as the IMF and the World
Bank in order to address the interests
of developing countries especially the
countries of the South this also
requires to actively
address any attempt to manipulate the
provisions of the charter or to
misinterpret those Provisions to justify
to justify the interference in the
internal affairs of certain member
states or to stoke bloody conflicts and
Stoke chaos and terrorism thus making
those countries to be left behind Mr
President my country Syria during the
last decade has been victim to the loss
of true multilateralism and to the
exploitation by certain countries of the
United Nations as a platform to serve
their hostile and interfering policies
in the Affairs of Syria Syria was left
alone to face the threats of the most
intractable and cruel terrorist groups
its resources and wealth
have been pillaged by certain foreign
forces that are illegally present on the
territories of Syria not withstand not
to mention the exacerbating humanitarian
suffering due to unilateral compulsory
measures that are totally illegal
inhumane and immoral that are imposed by
the United States and the European Union
and which have adversely affected all
the aspects of life and caused millions
of displaced persons and refugees only
foregoing are staggering and egregious
violations of the principles and
purposes of the charter of the United
Nations in conclusion I would like to
reiterate that today we are we do need
more than any time before to review the
methods of work of the United Nations
and to guarantee the promotion of true
multilateralism based on the charter by
upholding the purposes and principles of
the charter and by achieving the
objectives that were aspired to by the
founding fathers of the United Nations
together with upholding and promoting
the efficiency and efficacy of the
United Nations in order to uphold its
credibility Edge at the international
level thank you Mr President I thank the
representative of the Syrian air
Republic
and there are still speakers and scribes
on my list to deliver statements for
this meeting with the consent of member
states I intend to suspend this meeting
until 3 P.M the meeting is suspended